Hey, everybody, welcome to ROLLBACK, where we share
the best episodes from the pre-video,
audio-only RRP archive here on YouTube for the first time.
Today's edition is, I gotta tell you,
one of the most compelling, inspirational, cautionary
and grippingly cinematic stories
that I've ever heard in my entire life.
It's the story of one John McAvoy
and it's gonna blow your mind.
By way of brief introduction,
John was a guy who was born
into this notorious London crime family.
He eventually becomes a high-profile armed bank robber,
as one does.
He was then not surprisingly,
eventually busted, and sentenced to life in prison.
But through this insane series
of just absolutely incredible events
that I'm not gonna spoil, John ultimately pulls one of
the greatest 180-degree life transformations of all time,
going from this life centered around crime
to ultimately finding redemption in sport and along the way,
breaking British and world indoor rowing records,
becoming the only Nike-sponsored Ironman athlete
in the world.
And he's a guy who continues to inspire countless people
around the globe with his incredible story
of personal evolution and his advocacy for prison reform.
All of which makes this conversation one of
the most legendary in the history of this podcast.
So buckle up and enjoy episode 379,
recorded in the Summer of 2018, with John McAvoy.
(air whooshing)
And we're rolling.
John, so good to meet you, man.
I've been looking forward to this for a very long time.
So super stoked to have you share your story with me today.
Thank you for inviting me,
it's a huge honor and privilege,
and I'm looking forward to sharing it with you.
Yeah, good, good, good.
We're coming to everybody from a conference room
in Shorteditch, London.
It's a little cavernous in here,
so it might sound a little bit echoy in comparison
to the way that podcast usually sounds.
So you're just gonna have to bear with it,
but I think it's gonna be all fine, right?
'Cause you're gonna get so lost in John's story,
you're just, you're not even gonna know
what's happening.
Before we even get into that though,
what are you training for right now?
So my seasons starts in three weeks time,
I'm racing Ironman, Hamburg.
I was meant to be racing two weekends ago,
but obviously, training for Ironman,
you end up developing a lot of injuries,
especially as I'm getting a bit older.
So I had a problem of tendon in my foot.
So I've had to delay to start my race season,
but my season kicks off in three weeks time in Germany.
Cool, man.
So feeling good, injury-free?
Yeah, yeah, I'm much better now.
I've been a bit more consistent with my running.
I did, I wasn't able to run for three months,
which killed me, because running is actually the thing
that I enjoy the most outta training for Ironman.
But yeah, so I'm back on course now
and I'm ready to rock and roll in three week's time.
Right on, and you're 33 right now?
How old are you?
I'm 35 now.
35, 35.
I'm getting on now.
The gray hairs are coming out.
And to date, what is your like best performance?
My, probably my best performance
would've been Ironman Frankfurt two years ago.
So basically when I started doing Ironman in 2014,
I went for a stage where I went an hour faster
every race I did, and that sort of really took hold
when I did Ironman Frankfurt.
It was a massive step up in my form,
I did like nine hours.
I run nearly a sub three hour math
and with the back end of it.
Yeah, it was good and it was bad
because the thing that kind of let me down
was my right recycling a bit because I just lack
that riding, 'cause I didn't stop riding until I was 30.
So that technical element of riding a bike,
and my cornering and breaking, and that sort of stuff
like it cost me a little bit.
Well, I mean 2014 was your first iron man.
Yeah.
So you're still branding with this whole thing.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a massive learning process that I've been going through
because it was frustrating as well.
'Cause when I was doing my training
and I was training on indoor, like static bikes,
the numbers that I was generating,
like power output and my physiology,
like I know I was putting out the same sort of numbers
like for FTP tests that at what a lot of sort of like
decent pro iron man would be putting out.
But I didn't seem to be getting that translation
across into road cycling.
Because again, I just lacked the experience
of riding a bike and that's,
I've had to obviously work on it a lot
over the last few years and I progressively have got better,
but I used to be really, really bad.
Like I used to be famous when we'd go on training camps,
the Alps, I would descend on a bike quicker
than I would climb up the other side of the mountain.
'Cause I was just so frightened all the time,
holding the brakes.
So that's amazing.
There's a difference between the power
that you can generate in a lab and then translating that
into a real world context.
So that's like the learning curve for you.
It's totally different.
Like obviously all of my training that I've ever done
for obvious reasons has always been on static machines.
So like the row machine years ago whilst I was in prison.
And then when I come out of prison, I carried on trying.
I tried to become a professional rower,
but I took up that sport too late.
And that's why I decided to do Ironman.
So actually power generating on a static machine.
You got that cover.
I was very, very good light.
What kind of watts were you putting out?
So like I could hold like 365 watts
when I was like 71 kilo for half hour.
That's serious.
For people that are listening
that don't have a frame of reference,
that's like world class.
Obviously I was fortunate where the transition
between rowing on a indoor row machine, that power,
you tend to find a lot of rowers are very, very,
very strong when they make the transition
between rowing to cycling.
So obviously where it's a leg dominated sport.
And also, I just think you have the ability
to be able to hurt yourself.
Like I've never physically felt pain.
Like I felt on an indoor row machine in an Ironman
or cycling, nothing comes close,
like to that when you are on the rivet. Right.
Doing that a two K flat test,
'cause it's like the lap tape builds up
in every part of your body, your back, your legs,
your arms when you're on the row machine.
And I think that, in thinking about your story,
I mean, I think you have some genetic predisposition,
like an ability to generate huge amounts of power,
but your gift really is your ability
to suffer over long periods of time.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I would say that born through pain and life experience
as much as anything else.
Yeah, well like years ago,
I wouldn't have seen it like that,
but obviously some of the situations
that I found myself in as a young man
and some of the things that I did to myself,
like when I was in prison, when I was a young,
when a young teenager and I segregated myself
in an isolation cell for a whole year,
and that was like defiance against a system.
The reason why I chose to do that was
because I got moved to a prison and they tried
to take all my clothes off me to put me
in a special yellow boiler suit.
So the prison officers could identify
that I was an escape risk.
And I was brought up to absolutely despise
and hate the system and everything it stood for
government, politicians, banks.
And then when I found myself in prison,
the system become very real.
Those prison officers had locked me up were real people
and they took my freedom away from me.
And when they tried to take my clothes off me, I refuse.
And they took me down to this isolation cell
and they took my clothes off of me
and they gave me this shitty she suit
so the prison officers could identify
that I was an escape risk in the prison.
And then when the seven days was up,
'cause that was what I was originally put in there
for seven days up.
Seven days of solitary.
So solitary, they opened up the door and they said,
you're gonna go back onto main allocation
and you're gonna be a wining cleaner.
And again, I hated these people and I said,
there's no way I'm gonna go and do that.
That I'm not going to do it.
I'm not gonna clean up your rubbish every day.
So he put me back in front of the governor
and the governor said to me,
you're refusing another law for order.
And I said, yes.
He said, well, you're going back in that cell
for seven more days.
And he gave me seven days confined to cell again.
And then when I was in that process
and I was sitting in that cell, I read about Nelson Mandela.
And when I went to prison and I was a young man,
I made a decision I would not become institutionalized.
And when the librarian used to come around,
this lady from the library used to come around a trolley
and you take books off.
And I used to think I would not become institutionalized.
And I will educate myself to come out of here
and be a better criminal, not to change, not to rehabilitate
'cause I was brought up to believe that if you changed,
you was weak and the system had broken you.
So if you had rehabilitated and become a better person,
You became soft.
A criminal, wouldn't see it like that.
They would see the system had broken you.
So I had that mantra in my head.
And when I was reading this book about Nelson Mandela
and in the book, he said that when he was in prison,
he used to smoke tobacco
and he realized that the prison officers used to use that
as a punishment against him.
He stopped smoking cigarettes.
So then my head as as, at this point I was 19.
I thought,
if you think by putting me in this isolation cell,
that you're punishing me, I will take you away from you.
So when they come up to seven days to put me back up on the
wing, I refused.
And then I stayed in that room for 365 days.
By choice.
And they would come round Christmas.
And I remember this and I look back on it now,
like there was a prison officer.
I didn't see it at the time. I hated him.
But I remember he opened up cell Christmas
and he said to me, he was just about to go off shift.
And it was in the evening. It was about four o'clock.
So obviously it was Christmas people got,
I know earlier that day and he said to me,
"Do you wanna phone up your mom?"
And I said, "No."
And I remember he opened up my cell door and he said, look,
you can phone your mom up it's Christmas day.
And I refused, I don't wanna use the phone.
Because that would give them some tiny little bit
of power, if they gave you something,
they can take something away from.
And I think it was me trying to wrestle
control of me
taking control back of my body.
And also again, it was that arrogance of not wanting to show
them weakness that even though it was Christmas day,
I wouldn't break and they wouldn't get anything outta me.
And I would sit and at that time
I thought I was getting something over on them
when in fact I was only punishing myself
and I was only hurting myself,
but I didn't see it like that.
I saw myself at war with them and this was
about me being defiant and me not showing weakness
and me not giving into them.
Well, I want to explore like how that
ultimately ended up shifting.
And I want to get into like how you got there
in the first place.
But before we do that,
like walk me through the experience of being in solitary
for such a long period of time, like how that shapes you,
how you spend your time trying to expand your mind,
but also what you did physically.
So obviously you got 24 hours a day to fill up.
You get into a habit of going to sleep very early.
I used to make two choices as well when I was in there,
read and I would not sleep in a day.
I would not sleep my prison sentences off.
So some prisoners would sleep all day in a segregation
and I chose not to do that.
So I got into a routine and when I was a child,
I had no interest in sport or exercise whatsoever.
You never played sports where never an athlete.
Play football. I used to get put in goal.
I was the little overweight kid that couldn't kick a ball,
but they'd stick me in guard.
I'd always be the last kid to be picked and would go,
you can go and go.
But I had no, I never idolized athletes as a kid.
I never really had any interest in sport bar, soccer,
football, and that was about it.
But when I was in prison, when I was obviously locked up,
someone once said to me that when you go to prison,
you don't live, you just exist.
And I started off one day and I don't even know what
the trigger was,
but I started off doing press ups and I didn't know
the names of the exercises I was doing.
And then I would do press ups, step up.
So to get my chair myself,
put it up to the back of the wall and you could open up the
tiny little vent windows just to get bit of ventilation and
I up doing these step up and then, then I'll do sit up.
And then I start putting all the exercises together
and I'd do these circuits and I'd get up every morning
at half five, six o'clock.
And I, again, I was grossly unfit when I first
went to prison, I was overweight.
So when you began, like how many pushups could you.
Oh, not a lot. Not a lot.
You couldn't have been working out
like at the beginning, like half an hour, I'm done.
I kind of just kept pushing myself.
So when I've like, if I did 10,
the next time I'd wanna do 11 until I'll get the pain
and it hurt.
And that would make me feel alive.
And I would about the other exercises on do 10, 10, 10.
And then as the months progressed, obviously again,
I didn't realize what I was doing,
but I was obviously getting fit up.
I lost weight
and I'd end up doing a thousand of each exercise
and in total it used to take me anywhere between
like an hour to an hour and a half,
depending on what sort of exercises is it like,
what I chose to do within it.
But it used to make me feel live.
And again, it was me taking control back
from the prison officers back to myself.
And that would last in the morning from six to so of half
past seven and then I'd have my breakfast.
And then I would read.
And again, when I was in there
because of the sort of men that brought me up,
I remember so of one of my stepfather,
that was a in prison for long periods of time, 16 years.
And I asked him,
how did he stop himself from becoming institutionalized
before I went to prison.
And he used to listen to the radio every day
and he would make sure that he read newspapers
to stay connected to the real world.
'Cause he said, this is not my life.
And that is the, that is sort of, again,
the mantra that I took con I refused to accept where I was
and I used to think to myself, this is not my life.
So I wanna stay connected to the real world
outside of this wall.
And I I'd be avidly reading about current affairs.
And this is when I was quite young as well, like politics.
I would wanna stay in touch with what was happening in the
real world, 'cause this where I was at the moment,
these people would kidnap me
again that hadn't I broke the law
and I was in prison for it.
And your sentence, it was a life sentence.
Was it not?
Well that when I first went,
when I was a teenager, that was,
I got five years for possession of firearms.
And then when I went back the second time,
obviously, because I had previous convictions
and the judge expressed my links to the criminal underworld,
it was so extensive at such a young age.
He said, no matter what sentence he gave me that day,
I was still gonna come outta prison a young man,
'cause I was only 24.
And he said that he believed that my risk to the public
was so great that they would always need protecting from me.
He sentenced me to two life sentences
with a minimum tariff for five years.
And what that meant is 'cause sometimes people get confused
what a life sentence is.
So as we speak today,
I'm technically serving my prison sentence in the community.
So at any moment the police suspected I was involved
in any organized crime,
obviously with any organized criminals,
they could recall me straight back to prison
and I'd go back on to my life sentence
and then I'd have to go back up in front of a parole board
and demonstrate to them that I wasn't a risk to the public.
And that was what it was about.
It was about taking the burden of proof from the police
having to prove I was committing a crime
to them suspecting I was committing a crime
and it was easier to recall the back to prison.
So to this day you could easily go back
if you even tiptoed anywhere near any of this stuff.
Like even when I wanna go abroad to race,
I did a talk last week at Nike's European headquarters
in Amsterdam.
And I have to ask for a permission of my operation officer.
And then when I come back to the country,
I've go and report into it to prove that I've returned back
to United Kingdom.
So that will always hang over me.
I don't look at it like and be bitter and twisted about it.
Like I got the sentence,
I know why the judge gave it to me back then.
But my life's obviously moved on to such an extent now
that yeah, it would be nice if it wasn't hanging over me,
but it is how it is.
And there's no point in me stressing about it every day,
waking up thinking,
I've got this sentence hanging over my head, I've got a try.
Just let go of that.
'Cause I don't wanna become bitter and twisted
and angry over it.
Well you could be back in right now.
I mean you could still be in there, right?
So I mean, every day's a gift based upon,
that judge.
100%
And your actions.
100%.
And that is why I've got an appreciation of life
and how precious life actually is
because when you go to prison,
and again, like it's not a hard done by story.
Like I put myself in there by poor decisions that I chose to
make as a young man.
But when you go to prison,
it is as near to dying as what you could possibly get that
and being in the actual, being a life still
it's like you in tune your body into a concrete coffin.
And when you get those life sentences,
like, yeah, you've got a minimum tariff,
but I can remember the day when my minimum tariff expired,
I went to bed and woke up the next day
and I'm still in prison.
And then you realize how powerless you are to actually,
if the system doesn't want to let you out,
you will stay in there for the rest of your life
if you don't play the game with them.
So books, you read the "Nelson Mandela" book.
What were the other books that were impactful on you?
"Malcolm X" there's like a list of,
there's like a bibliography of books
that are most commonly read in prison.
I think when, when I was in there, like I,
I was very interested in history.
I've always had this fascination even since
when I was a little kid,
I think that was one of the catalysts why I ended up doing
what I'd done when I was a kid.
So my biological father passed away before I was born.
And my mum explained to me about he died
and I was only young, I was like five, six years old
when I was going to primary school
and 'cause kids kept teasing me where my dad was
and my mum, she explained to me what death was.
And I was too young to really understand what legacy was.
But I divert this sensational appetite for history.
Like I can remember my mom used to get me these magazines
every month called discovery booklets.
And it'd be about an Napoleon, Winston Churchill.
And I can remember being a little boy and hundreds of years
after these men were dead,
people were still reading about them and they're left
the footprint on the earth.
And that motivated me.
Like I remember thinking like I don't just,
I die that I wanna achieve something with my life.
And that thread of that wanting to learn about the past
always stayed with me.
So when I was in prison,
I kept reading about the past because I still wanted
that legacy.
I still wanted to achieve so my life.
And when I decided to make that connection
about changing years later, I, like I said,
when I read "Lance Armstrong's Autobiographies"
that had a profound impact on me,
that opened up my eyes to a possibility of like the
characteristics that I had
that I was using like the will, the drive,
the wanting to achieve something with life,
wanting to be successful.
The only people that I ever met in my life
with those characteristics were all involved
in organized crime.
Then suddenly I was open up to this man that did sport
and they were massive attributes
and he was successful.
And then I started reading these other books of all these
sort of Olympic athletes and endurance athletes.
And again, they all had the same reoccurring blueprint
of the same characteristics.
But you're thinking at the time,
like how you can channel those characteristics
to become a master criminal.
And honestly like Rich,
I'm very fortunate that since I've been outta prison,
I have a lot of friends and associates
that have gone to the Olympics and they've meddled,
they've won gold medals at the Olympic games,
very pinnacle in rowing in what sport they've chosen to do.
They've been highly successful.
They worked for like Goldman Sachs, me Lynch,
big financial institutions.
And when we train together and there's a couple of them,
we go for runs on the weekend, like long runs
and I've said to them before you would be amazed,
the conversations that we are having about the world
I'd be having is that the same conversations
with people that were in prison for being contract killers,
for people involved in drug trafficking,
you would be amazed the similarities in the mindsets of
the two of them, but how from a young person,
their lack of opportunity or the bad role models
that have come into their lives that have walked
what they've then chosen to do with those characteristics
and they've been exposed to criminality and they've thrown
that into crime and they was exposed to role in,
or at a sport and their fathers work
for big corporate banks and they've chosen that path
and it even fascinates me sometimes like
the similarities and the conversations
between two groups of people
and the mindsets are exactly the same.
That's profound and fascinating, the same mindset,
the ability to focus uniquely on a specific goal
and work your way towards that,
whether it be criminal or athletic or professional.
I can see how those traits would cross over
and the differentiators of course, the environment.
That's amazing.
Gimme a taste of like that kind of come conversation
amidst the criminal underworld.
'Cause I know what the athlete conversations are like.
Obviously in the criminal fraternity,
everything revolves around money, acquiring money,
making lots of money.
You tend to find with a lot of people that commit crime
they've got that a lot of normal members of society
haven't got is there's no real cutoff switch.
Like there's nothing they're not really prepared to do
that I was brought up of a moral compass
and you don't hurt women, you don't hurt children,
you don't sell heroin.
You don't attack old people,
you don't attack the working man,
but this is system and everything the system is,
is fair game.
And everyone that I was round as a criminal,
all had that same belief system.
And so you tend to tend to find your whole conversations
were based around making money,
but making it through the system.
And that would be through sort of committing robberies,
people committing fraud, but all against,
not against business, but against guy.
There is a code, right?
And the way that you see it,
my only frame of reference is what you see on television
and movies,
but if you watch good fellows or the Sopranos
and movies of that ilk stories told of that ilk,
like there's always that code, right.
And that code cannot be transgressed.
And in when you're part of that universe,
it all makes sense.
Like my stepdad used to say to me,
when I was a young boy must have been that 10, 11 years old.
The only thing in that world that you've got is your name.
And if people don't respect you,
'cause you've informed on your friends
or informed on anyone and you sort of grasp ratted people
out and talk to police anything, your name's finished.
And the only thing you have ever got is that as a criminal,
it goes before you, like,
if people don't think what you call class
and crime in this country is being any good
that that's the end of you is
doing what you're doing,
being involved in criminal activity.
But like again,
if I was ever disrespectful to a woman in any way,
like touched a woman, was disrespectful verbally to her,
my stepdad would've gone, absolutely mad.
My mum would gone, absolutely mad, but my stepdad
would not tolerate it.
You always treat women with respect
because your mom's a woman, your sister's a woman.
and I found that quite fascinating
because as my life's progressed,
since I've been outta prison,
it's been occasions where I've met women
and their parents have found out about my past
and the kind of like all you gotta be careful,
but the iron of it is,
they'd probably be safer with me
than they would for someone else.
And I've always found that quite ironic
because the way I see a woman.
You can't blame them though.
You know what I mean?
(both laughing)
That's so funny.
Like yeah, armed robbery, no problem.
Good on you, pat on the back, but sort of set a weird thing
to a woman or touched her inappropriately
and like not so good.
So let's take it back to the beginning.
So you never really knew your biological father.
But give me a sense of like the family
that you grew up in, what the environment was like.
So my actual biological father, he died
whilst my mom was eight months pregnant with me.
So he went to bed one night.
He was 38 years old and had a massive heart attack.
It was, there was no symptoms.
There was nothing leading into it that led him
to believe he had a bad heart.
My mom said that he was an absolute workaholic.
Like he wasn't a criminal.
He owned nightclubs, betting offices.
He had shops, construction business,
but all legitimately.
My mum used say to me, he used to..
Does that smell sort of like it does the terrain
of the monster.
It does and all of, to be fair,
all of his brothers,
like they were from a big Irish Catholic family.
A lot of them were involved in crime.
But my dad, my mom used say, my dad used
to look at them and think they were idiots
because he could see the right
and was on the wall with them.
But what my dad did because my mom told me
that because like he owned stuff like nightclubs,
and then he owned Betting offices
because he had these different sorts of businesses,
he was staying up all night at the nightclub,
making sure that people wasn't stealing money.
And then he was waking up again at five,
six o'clock in the morning and then going out
in the construction business.
So he was surviving on very little, it sleep, lot of stress.
And anyway, bad diet dies at 38 years old.
I get born into the world and I had a relatively sort of
what I class as a normal upbringing, like I wasn't abused.
Christmas has come around. Everything I ever wanted.
My mom loved me. I had loads of aunts.
No real men coming to our life.
My mom was single, only uncles come into our home
and it was just a normal childhood.
Like I said earlier on the only thing that really made
it a bit different was when I started going
to primary school,
people used to tease me about not having a dad.
And I asked my mom and my mom told me my dad died.
And then my life completely changed
when I was eight years old.
And before my mom met my father,
my mom grew up in a place in south London called Packham.
And she grew up on a Kanza estate.
And she grew up with a man called Billy Tobin.
And they grew up as kids and when they were 16,
they're both Catholics, they get married.
My mom falls pregnant with my sister when she's 18.
They're just a normal young family in London.
Billy goes out his dad one night
and he is working as a plasterer
and he sees his dad get in a pub and free men
stubs dad's death.
When that happened, Billy's life then completely spiraled.
And then I dunno,
I couldn't tell you what was going through his head,
but I could only imagine he then looked at life
and he then went on a journey of becoming a normal guy,
plaster young family
to becoming one of the most prolific arm robbers
in the United Kingdom.
He had five acquits at the Old Bailey.
The police shot him two times arm robbers.
He was a multimillionaire when he is 21.
8 Years old, this man comes outta prison
after serving 16 years.
And he come into our home.
When I lived in crystal palace with my mom in south London,
first time I will ever, I seen this man.
And he was, I can remember it as clear as day
like he come in, I was a young kid.
I'm looking at him.
He was in mackily dressed massive gold watch.
And he come in our home and he asked me
to make him a cup of tea and I made him a cup of tea.
And then as he was leaving our house,
he gave me a 20 pound note.
And it was the first time anyone had ever given me paper
on that.
I took this 20 pound note off him and he patted me
on the head and he went, you're a good boy.
And he left. And I said to my mom, who is he?
And my mom explained to me that it was her ex-husband.
He didn't say like, "Hey, if you want a job,
come and see me."
No, no he didn't.
He is for very cinematic.
It's like I can see it happening just like in the movies.
He, to be honest, he never ever, ever, ever talk.
So he didn't come into my life to my mum's life again,
to be in a romantic relationship.
But obviously 'cause of my sister.
He's around.
He's around. He didn't live with my mum.
He was living his own life.
And when he used to take my sister out out,
he would take me out.
He didn't have a son.
I didn't have a dad.
So you can already see what starts happening here.
And he never, ever, ever mentioned to me anything he did.
And he would take me to these restaurants
and there'd be a lot, again, a young kid,
lot of older men, big watches, nice cars outside.
People stopping by the table to say hello.
All of that stuff like going into restaurants,
being in good tables, never having to queue.
You could see when you were into clothes shops,
the people in the clothes shops treated them differently.
Everything was cash.
Christmas would come around.
And I remember like,
they're all putting money together and giving you like a
thousand pounds, when I was a young boy.
Always, always, always talking about money.
Every conversation was about money and that was it.
But no one really went into detail where the money
was coming from.
And again, you were a young boy,
I couldn't connect the dots up.
And it was only when my granddad died,
that me and my mom and my aunties went round
to my granddad's flat to clear it out.
And as I opened up this drawer,
there was a massive envelope.
And I opened up this envelope and it had
all of these front page, newspaper clippings
from all like the national tabloid newspapers.
And it was basically Billy on the front of them.
And it was like Harry sort of novel juries, which meant,
and corrupt juries paid them off to find, not guilty.
How the met police were after him for years
and how he was the most influential bank robber
in the country and that organized crime
and millions of pounds.
And I was reading all these newspaper clippings.
And then I then connected up the dots
where all of this sort of this money.
And you're how old at this point?
I was 12 years old.
That didn't send me over the edge that wasn't t
the catalyst for me deciding to do what I did
that come a little bit further along.
But it all started happening around the same sort of time.
I asked Billy about this and he didn't really wanna
talk about it.
He didn't ever, ever really talk about
when he was in prison.
He didn't like really doing it unless I really
used to push him on it.
But then when I was 12, big TV channel in his country, ITV,
there was a doc, there was a film.
So they're not documentary of film.
And this film was about my real brother,
my real dad's brother.
And he committed the biggest arm robber in the world.
And he sold 26 million pounds worth of gold billion
at Heathrow Airport.
Wow.
And when I'd go out and be as a young kid, again,
all the dots are connecting up.
Everyone would go, is that Mickey's nephew?
And I never used to really question it.
and everyone used to always like,
that was why they was giving me the money at Christmas.
And that was why they was always making sure
that if I wanted anything, like, do you want a drink?
Do you want this? Do you want that?
So Mickey got killed or he was in prison.
He was in prison.
Mickey McAvoy.
Yeah.
And he got 25 years the arm robbery of Stephen
and the Goldie Bully.
So way of paying respect to Mickey
was to slip you cash.
Yes.
Because within crime, in United Kingdom,
obviously it was the biggest arm robber in the world.
You are then dealing with men that hate the system.
You've attacked the system on an imaginable scale
and stolen,
which if you put it into today's money
would probably be a couple of hundred million pounds
over gold bullying.
Cause this was like 1983.
So if you put into real world terms
to that, how much money that be worth.
So within the criminal underworld in this country,
it was the pinnacle of doing anything against the system.
And then you've got this young kid that's then out
with this very high profile I'm robber
that's then going into this world with other high profile,
organized criminals as a blood relative of that man.
So then what that then started doing
when I watched that film,
that film inspired me that night and honestly Rich,
I genuinely feel embarrassed to say,
but it inspired me to become a criminal.
I didn't see the fact that my uncle was in prison
for 25 years for that offense.
So I saw Hollywood actor sitting on 26 million pounds
worth of gold bullion.
And that to me at that moment was pathway
for how I could become rich
and how my definition of success was how much money
I would make.
And that was the pathway in which I was gonna choose
to do it.
So then really that sort of age, I then started death,
complete disinterest in school, complete disinterest.
And we're talking about
when we're talking about like a criminal enterprise
and we're talking about armed robbery,
we're not talking about holding people up on the street,
you're talking major bank robberies,
like big heist and an organization structure
beneath this that's supporting this endeavor, right?
So how vast was the enterprise?
When I started getting involved in crime,
when properly when I left school, when I was 16,
I sat my GSEs 'cause my mum played with me to sit them.
But I knew that if I got an English or maps,
it wasn't gonna get me what I wanted in life,
but I I'd done my GSEs.
and I remember when I sat there and
I got my grades at the end of the summer,
my head of year was there and he gave them to me.
And he, if only you would've applied yourself,
what you could have done.
And I still managed to salvage and decent grades
considering I did none of the coursework lead then.
And I got these qualifications, I ripped them up,
chucked them in the bin at the end of my school drive.
And I thought, I know what I'm gonna go and do.
My stepdad found out that I bought a firearm when I was 16.
And in his head,
he believed that I would be safe for committing crime
with them than I would be people my own age.
And as perverse as that is like it is.
There's a logic there though.
It's a sense of protecting you
and trying to prevent me from killing myself
or killing someone else.
And meanwhile, your mom had to see the signals.
So where is she in this?
My mom, like when I was a young boy growing up
to the degree my mom would not even let me play
with sort of toy guns like cowboys.
She would not like she did everything she could
to shield me to the degree she told Billy
never, ever, ever take him and do anything with him.
So when he would swing by
and take you out to these restaurants,
I mean, she must have said at some point like, look,
you gotta stay away from this guy.
She did.
But the problem that you start getting is
when you're a young teenager or a young man,
you become harder and harder and harder
for your mom to control what you're doing.
'Cause you always think your mum's wrong.
Like, look back now my mom,
everything my mom said was right,
but it's very hard for a woman to control a young man
that then around these such dominant, strong alpha males
that are enticing you into that world.
It's like a lot of those guys
that I knew as growing up as kids,
a lot of their kids went to private schools.
They had the best education you could afford to by basically
they all went private schools.
They went on lavish holidays around the world.
They had nice things, tennis courts in the garden,
every single one of those kids left that private school
and they become drug traffickers and they've all ended up
in prison, but they had the best of everyone.
And that just shows you what happens
when you have that terrible role model.
Like they've had the best of everything.
They come outta school with top grades,
top school and come out and end up selling drugs
because their dad sold drugs.
And it wasn't discouraged.
In fact, most of the time dad's got the sons on board
and the son's got involved in their empire
and their drug empires or got involved
in whatever criminality they committing.
My stepdad realized that I was following him in that line.
So like I said, he fought in a full sense of protecting me.
He'd be safe if I committed crime
with him than other people.
So he then basically used to get me to go out
and with video cameras and I would film lorries
making deliveries to security depots in the suburbs
and they would basically fill up the security depots
and I'd give these CCTV takes.
So it's like, recard
you're scoping out a job.
You gotta figure out how the money's flowing.
So you know where the vulnerabilities are.
It's like my role in it become,
I used to be very good at memorizing number plates.
So like I look back on it now.
So I would go out in a car or a motor bike.
And obviously if you are delivering money
to sort of banks in armor trucks that you,
so we call them security vans, but armor trucks,
The same van used to make the same delivery
on the same day, every week, week on week on week.
And you knew how many sort of how many times
he's walking in the bank, how much he was taking in
and out the bank.
So you would know on a Thursday,
they was delivering X amount of hundreds of thousands
of pound into each bank.
These guys that work for these companies,
aren't looking at a 17, 16 year old kid.
They're looking for middle aged men, stocky, stubble,
like your typical criminal,
not some sort of spotty teenager,
that's a little bit overweight, chubby.
They're not looking at me as a threat.
So it's very easy for you to like get near them
and count and look and observe.
And then part me lay that information back on.
I realized very quick that my goal was to be a millionaire.
That that was it, bottom line.
And I set myself goals.
I wanted to be worth a million pound
when I was 21 years old.
And then as I got older, I wanted more and more money,
but there was these goals.
And was your stepdad like,
"Look, we're gonna bring you in.
We're gonna start you with small stuff, but be patient.
And you will be a millionaire."
Like, was it overt and explicit like that?
Well, the only way I can explain what he was like.
So he never used to stop telling me
that he was a millionaire when he was 21.
That, so that was why that stuck in my head.
And he always used to say to me,
do you think you'll beat me?
And it was like a test and even little things
like when I was at school, he had a Paul 911,
and I was being a bit cheeky to my mom.
'Cause I was chewing in didn't wanna go to school.
And I said, we live too far.
Don't wanna go, I ain't get in the bus.
And he said, take the car that I'm 16 years old.
And I said, what?
He said, take the car.
He said, if you are a big man, take the car, drive the car,
drive to school.
So I said, all right.
So I took his car and I drove the car to school.
Now, most adults, you wouldn't let a child drive any car,
but let alone a car that, but it was always,
that was what he was like.
He was always testing.
He was always seeing how much bottle I had
and did I have that sort of capability to keep pushing it?
And what started happening
when I was out with him and I remember this
and he was relaying these stories onto older men,
that at this time I knew that we were revolving crime.
They would lavish praise on you
and they would show you respect.
And that starts feeding into psychology as a young man,
especially a young a boy.
And you're getting these like 40,
50 year old men saying, God, you got some, but like,
I wouldn't have done that when I was a kid
and that starts feeding into it.
And then you start again, you've got no fear.
I had no fear.
I didn't fear the police.
I was brought up didn't mean anything to me.
for E prison, police.
None of that bothered me at all.
I had literally zero fear.
So if they said to me,
go and drive 10 guns to the other side of the country,
I would've put them in a car and drove there.
'Cause it was all. And they actually did.
I was gonna say that was a test,
but they actually did do that.
There was a couple of times where they did do that.
And sometimes I look back on it now
and I think they're kind of exploiting me
to a degree and I didn't, I was too young
to understand that I thought I was in,
I was in with them.
And when actually it was
about me taking these massive risks.
'Cause you're the one who's gonna take the fall.
And you're expendable.
The amazing thing is that we'd all like to think
that if we found ourselves in your shoes,
that we would make a different choice
and it's just not how it works.
it's like this slow drip of you growing up
in this certain environment and a billion small encounters
and exchanges with people that leads you to that place
where the obvious choice is to do exactly what you did.
And that if I had grown up in that environment,
that I would've made the same choices.
Do you know what Rich,
that's did me like so much
what I've gone on to do with my life,
because I can have this conversation
that we're having right now with a politician
and I've had countless times,
I've met people in authority and they sit
across the table for me and they go,
I cannot see how you've gone to prison for what you've gone
in there for even when I was in prison, on parole hearings,
I'm sitting in my probation officers
that have been in that system for years.
And they're like looking at a foul, looking at me,
looking at a foul, looking at me going,
I cannot see how you come across the way you do.
And you've done this and what that has done for me is
I can express and show them
what can happen to young people.
The most intelligent, articulate, driven, focus, young men,
that there are up and down this country
when negative people come into their lives
and how that intelligence and drive, and focus,
can compete completely and utterly warped.
And that's why we've got this huge problem in our country
at the moment with young kids killing each other,
getting involved in gangs like in America,
they're not like ambitious and they're not driven.
Like they're incredibly ambitious and driven,
but it's all channeled into the wrong thing
because the wrong people have come into their lives
and channeled that energy into something so destructive.
And they don't see the destructive nature of
what they're really doing until it eventually leads
to them being killed or spending their lives in prison.
A big part of what you do,
probably the most important part,
everyone knows you as this triathlete,
but with this incredible story,
but it's your advocacy on behalf of prison reform.
that I think holds the most power to really shift culture.
And if you just scroll through your Twitter feed,
like you're constantly talking about
what's not going right, what needs to be changed.
There was just the thing the other day
about somebody's trying to get incarcerated individuals
into sport while they're incarcerated,
but it was like dismissed or something like that.
And you had a few words to share about that.
Like, so you talk yeah.
A tabloid newspaper, sort of the,
with political agendas that don't necessarily
want things to change.
When I was in prison the second time,
there were 85,000 men incarcerated,
there was 28 of us at that 85,000 that were deemed
to such a higher risk
that we had to be put in a special high security prison unit
in Belmar prison called the Hsu.
We were completely at least segregated
at the whole prison system because we were either deemed
to be a threat national security
or our escape was so highly likely.
And we did escape.
We post such a risk to the police
that escape must be made impossible.
And I was kept to that unit for two years
with Islamic suicide bombers.
The system wrote me off, said I'll never change.
Were you were in there with like Hamza?
So Shakabu Hamza, right?
The 21 seven suicide bombers
that tried to blow themselves up on the underground system.
And the guys that tried to actually blow up
the transatlantic flights,
going over to the states with I liquid it bums.
So I'm in there with them.
I'm told basically you are here because
we believe you're gonna escape.
And the likelihood of you changing got two life sentences
is so slim it will not happen.
And I can remember someone from the home office who was like
the ministry of justice come into the prison.
And I was trying to get off this unit to try to get
into the main prison because I did actually wanna try
to escape or get out as fast as I could.
And she said, "We are not stupid.
We know people like you will never, ever, ever change."
Because again, serious crime.
and if I've managed to do what I've done through sport,
why come aren't the other 85,000 people do it?
And that's what makes me so passionate because I understand
that once I had an awaken in prison
and I wanted to do something else with my life,
and I discovered sport, what sport done for my life
and sport allowed me to be successful.
It's given everything that I've got today.
And it isn't even about being a good athlete.
It's about what it's done for my life.
It's about the people it's brought into my life,
incredible people, not just Olympic athletes,
but it's allowed me to go in and speak to kids.
Thousands of them up and down the country.
I've met some of the most amazing,
incredible people I've ever met in my life through sport.
Now it mean you have to come out,
you have to break world records in prison,
but it gives you access and exposure to positive people.
And that is what's sport done.
And when I got released from prison,
my social circle completely changed overnight.
And I'm friends with nearly everyone that I was friends with
when I first come out and it broke me away from that those
negative people that were involved in crime.
And I know sport can play such a huge role in helping
so many different sorts of people, not just criminals,
but people in life, it's such a powerful thing.
And I'm such an advocate of it because I've experienced it
in my own life.
And as I said, like, you are not gonna meet anyone
as it from that extreme of crime than me.
Like, I will a wholeheartedly say that
I was one of the most entrenched criminals you'd ever meet
in your life.
I wasn't a horrible bully.
I didn't bully normal people walking up down.
I wasn't that sort of like mafia, Don boss,
like went down and bullied people and tried to take money
from restaurants and stuff.
But I was driven by greed and it every day
and sport has allowed me to get of that up.
I would imagine one thing you come across regularly
is this idea that the more you accomplish,
the more you achieve, the more you become an outlier
so that somebody can say to you,
yeah, John, like, look what you did,
but you're the unique example.
Like this is not gonna be the case
for all these other people.
So like, why even try.
I would say to you,
I would say to anyone that says that like
I've gone and visited prisons and I've gone and visited
young offenders in schools,
and I'm not the only person.
There on countless stories of other people
that have used sport and it's play some massive role
in their lives.
And they've, it's allowed them other opportunities
to be better people.
Again, I understand there's varying,
there's varying levels of it.
And I know I've probably taken it to the extreme
because of the characteristics of which I've always
possessed the ambition of drive.
I was in prison.
I mean, I was good at sport, wanted to be a millionaire,
next thing was, I wanna be a professional athlete,
but I've always had that diet.
I've always been ambitious and driven.
and I know you can get varying levels of that,
but it's about what sport can just give people
to be better people and access.
And as I said, again, it comes back.
So, like I said earlier about having negative role models
in people's lives,
this can expose them to positive role models
in people's lives.
And I've also noticed that when I go into these prisons
and I talk to inmates,
you are far more likely to get someone
to do something productive with their life
if they're passionate about what they're doing.
And I am yet to go into a prison or a young offender
and talk to an inmate one on one.
So you tend to find,
I've got this sort of, I'm fortunate where,
when I go into a prison environment,
prisoners don't see me as the system.
They don't see me as enemy.
So they're quite open with their talking.
So they they'd be quite open about what they really think.
And the amount of conversations I've had with inmates where
they've gone.
I said like, what would you want to do if you got out of it?
And it's been be a personal trainer,
be a coach, work with children, give back.
They never say be a better criminal.
But I don't wanna be,
but if they want you to turn it,
like they want to change.
It's it's about,
you're more likely to get them to stick at it,
if they're passionate about it.
And most prisoners in prison are passionate about gym.
The gym is the most popular thing in prison,
other than food.
So their food, then it'll be gym.
And the take up rate again like,
I was having this conversation with ministry of justice,
like within the prison system.
So ethnic minorities make up,
I think 25% of our prison population.
They attend the gym more regularly than Caucasian men
in the gym system, in the prison system, in this country.
So you can engage with some of the most disenfranchised
people involved in gang activity,
straight away you you've got them in,
they're susceptible then to change.
And if you say, "Look."
You've shown them positive role models,
and you've shown them ways that way they can get away
from that life by becoming a personal trainer
while doing something that they're passionate about,
when they get released,
they're far more likely to stick at it
than if you basically give them a qualification
that they've got no interest in in doing that
when they get out of prison.
I mean, I'm not that familiar
with UK's prison system and I'm certainly no expert
in the prison industrial complex in the United States.
But at the core of this whole thing
is not just punishment, but rehabilitation
and we've just lost any appreciation
for how to properly rehabilitate people
when they're in prison.
There doesn't seem to be very much energy put into that.
And what we do is we just create,
we're just perpetuating and increasing
the criminal underclass as a result.
And in the United States,
I don't know what the statistics are, but
it's far more ethnic and minority than I would imagine
it is here.
And the prisons are privatized.
So we have a built in incentivization to incarcerate
more and more people keep them in there longer and longer
and longer because money is being made
and there are vested interest in lobbying groups
that are trying to only increase the scope of a system
that is inherently broken.
And what you are saying there is
if you look at like the European model of incarceration,
so the United Kingdom hands out more life sentences a year,
than the whole continent of Europe puts together.
That's staggering.
Our justice model is far more similar to yours in the states
than it is Europe.
And we've got what, 12 miles of water between us and them.
Between us and like continent, Europe,
and again, privatization of prisons incentivizing.
So another example,
I went into a prison recently, so a prisoner was being paid,
so he had no money so he was in prison.
He's got no cash outside, no real family.
He's been paid to go to the workshops, five pound,
a session to make a fire effects.
So he's either got that choice or earning one pound 50
to go to English or maths.
He's got no money. So what does he pick?
He wants to buy tobacco and he wants to buy tin.
So he goes and pick file.
And he even said to me,
what am I gonna do when I get out of prison
making file faxes.
And that is the problem. Like you've just said.
If you incentivize that part of prison
and you start putting in call centers
and you pan them 50 per a session,
you give them like five, six sessions a day
and they're earning like 20, 30 pounds per week,
or they're gonna do education and learn something
can better their lives.
And they're only getting paid four pounds a week.
It's quite simple where they're gonna go,
where that flow's gonna end up going.
And then you get this huge problem.
Like we've got the moment where it's costing
15 billion pounds a year on people
just coming outta prison and going straight back in again
within a year.
It's a huge, huge, huge recidivism.
So if you had your druthers,
what is the reform that you would like to see
that you think is actually achievable?
I think there has to be a, I think it has to,
I do generally believe that sport in prisons
could be a far more powerful used tool
than it is at the moment.
As things stand, it's like a dog chasing its tail.
Like there's a shortages of prison officers
that needs to increase.
Because again, if you haven't got the prison officers,
you can't let the prisoners out to engage
and access the courses and stuff to help them
sort of change.
But I believe sport could play a far more pivotal role
in what it actually does at the moment,
like sport and exercise in prisons is used,
but it's not used to the degree in which it could.
I think if you used it in prisons,
I think straight away a prison officer will tell you this
violence would drop dramatically.
'Cause you are allowing young men to vent that anger
and frustration through physical activity
whilst still in prison.
And again, I think you,
they're no more susceptible to change.
I think that they won't necessarily just keep getting up
every morning, be driven by hatred towards the system.
And again, lots of in the gym setting in prisons
that relationship's so different to the relationship it is
between guards that work on the prison wings and prisoners.
A prison officer has changed my life.
If it wasn't for that Darren Davis,
the prison will sit loud ingrained
that didn't just notice my athletic ability,
but he actually had an interest in me being successful
with no agenda.
Like he used to come in on his days off and sit with me
as I've tried to break some of the records
on the Ram machine
and he'd bring me in books and he'd talk about his family
and I've developed a relationship with him
and that's taboo like-
Yeah, you're not supposed to do that.
That does not happen.
And that just shows you like when you get people
like the prison officers that if you have,
if they're like Darren and they can reach out to people
and they treat them like human beings and go,
I want you to be successful,
a lot of these young men,
it's the first time someone's ever really wanted
that for them.
But I would imagine a lot of these officers,
they're just hardened.
They're used to being on the receiving end of
a lot of difficult situations
and they become emotionally checked out.
So I mean, how unique was the scenario
where this guy took an interest in you?
He is a very special man.
Like that without a doubt.
Like he, the way he,
and that's that wasn't just with me,
that's what he's continues to do of his job to today.
Like he, the way he treats inmates,
he treats them like humans.
He gives him a chance,
like to the degree where there's been occasions,
where he's had altercations,
where our prisoners and the prisoners are stuck up for him
over the other prisoners
when they've been out of arguments.
I think someone like Darren and me together collectively,
we can change mindset because I think you can go in
and talk to these prison officers and say,
you're not just paid here to open up a door and lock it up.
You are here, like you are the frontline to help
these men change their lives and show them
there's job satisfaction.
And you actually are being appreciated
that you're doing a massive task
because also of course like you,
when I've gone into prison,
you talk to the prison officers that you, I totally get.
If you are underpaid and you don't feel like the system
and the government really looking after you,
you've got complete disinterest in your job really.
Like, and if you've got no passion for it
and you look at prisoners like scumbags,
and you just think I'm just gonna lock them out.
Like, I can't bother to deal with him.
I'm not paid enough,
again, the circle just keeps continuing.
And these guys get out and they foster more hatred toward
the system and they come out and then
the offending gets progressively worse.
So you should go, maybe you already do this,
but when you go and you give talks,
you should go out together with him, right?
You guys do that?
Yeah, We've done some joint talks together,
but it's something definitely like, I wanna develop as,
'cause obviously I've got the balance act at the moment
with what I'm doing for in "Ironman".
And then once that sort of that's put to bed
that will free me up a lot more to do a lot more things
that I wanna sort of do.
Right, right, right.
Well, let's, let's bring it back to,
this sort of the development of your criminal career.
So you're scoping out the armored trucks
and when does it get like more serious
to where you're actually committing these crimes
and participating in them?
So that was when I was like 17,
I then started getting more and more involved
and my stepdad gets arrested.
Loads of his associates got arrested
and he was the only one that wasn't arrested.
And I remember the morning of his arrest.
I said to him, "Look, you need to go."
And he was so arrogant.
He was like, "They'll never be able to touch me."
And then later on that day they did,
they ended up arresting him with armed police.
So I knew it was probably highly probable
that the police were probably aware of me.
And again, my arrogance was,
"They can't do nothing to me."
There's not enough evidence.
There was enough evidence.
They would already arrested me 'cause they knew where I was
and they didn't touch me.
But what they did do,
they set a surveillance operation up on me.
And when I was gonna go and commit an offense, one morning,
they were waiting ambush.
And basically cars come from everywhere.
I had this car chase, I got away originally.
It was the furthest I'd ever run.
Like I can remember I jumped over all these garden fences
and I was being chased by police.
And I actually got away from them and I felt like
I was gonna have an asthma attack because I was so unfit.
And I was in this telephone box.
What was the crime you were trying to commit?
So we was waiting for, well,
we went there to not night before to park up all the cars.
And we were gonna commit a robbery on a cash and transit van
that was making a delivery to the post office.
So what we did,
we went there the night before to park the cars up
in the vicinity and the police had watched us do this.
So they knew it was gonna happen next morning.
And then they basically were waiting in ambush for us.
And then on the way there, they decided to try to arrest us.
And I swear the car chase happened.
And as I said, I got away from the actual car chase
and I was jumping over all these garden fences
and I got to a telephone box.
And I remember I always 20 pounds in my sock
to get a taxi home if anything ever went wrong.
And the next thing I heard a screech and I looked around
and I saw this massive man running towards me
with a gun pointing to me.
And I thought I was dead.
Like I genuinely fall I'm dead.
And He, they all,
he come run into the phone box and there was loads of others
in my peripheral vision.
They dragged me on the floor and then he identified himself
as a police officer.
And I thought, oh, thank God for that.
Like I thought I was gonna be killed.
And so that was your first arrest?
Yes.
And did they get you,
were they trying to spin you or roll you
to get some bigger names or?
Yeah, yeah. Like, yeah.
'Cause you're the young,
you're the lowest on the totem pole,
They were trying to intimidate me,
but then when we got to the police station,
like there was a very famous criminal lawyer in Britain
and every most high profile criminals use him.
So when I got to the police station, like.
It's getting more and more like a movie.
He was like a family lawyer
and he basically was on the phone.
He said, "Don't tell him nothing.
I'll send someone down."
And then I was there for three days
and then they tried to get really parry review.
And it's all like, you are really sort of,
oh, like your uncle.
And they try to like,
they try to become proud with you, even though they're not,
they're trying to get snippet.
They're trying to get you to lessen the mask.
'Cause you let something slip out.
And I was there for three days and it was just no comment,
no comment, no comment.
And it was, he was well drilled on it.
He was well drilled not to tell him anything.
I didn't tell him my name and address.
I didn't tell him, I like my date of birth.
I was being as awkward as I possibly could be.
And they let you go.
No, they didn't let me go.
Oh, they didn't.
No, that was when I.
So is that when you got the five years?
Yes.
Ah, okay.
So you were like,
you were just fresh out of the gate.
Like your career hadn't even really quite begun yet.
No, but that was the downside to mixing
with such high profile criminals.
So I was mixing with criminals that had been doing
what they'd been doing for 20, 25 years.
Lots of them have never really been arrested
or they had that.
Billy had been outta prison that point for that 11 years,
they wasn't sort of revolving doors of prisoners in and out,
in and out and out.
It's just that when they went in,
they went in for huge periods of time
and then come back out and just carried on doing
what they did before they went in there.
And how often was it getting violent?
Like how often were the guns getting discharged and.
Very rare.
People getting hurt.
Very, very rare.
Very, no, no one, no one ever got hurt.
In fact, like I was, again,
my stepdad always just say to me,
when I was young about
you don't need to be violent towards people.
It's all about verbalizing and talking.
So it was never like that, you would watch a movie,
a Hollywood film and everyone's running around
with the machine guns letting them off into the sky
and stuff.
It wasn't like that at all.
It was very controlled, very verbalized,
very taking control of a situation verbally,
letting them know that using control
and people get lost to that sometimes
again, 'cause you see these films
and things get glamorized and you watch some people,
with machine guns,
shooting helicopters and stuff and right.
And it actually isn't like that.
But it wasn't to the degree where the people
that I was with, should I say.
What else are the differences
between the reality versus what you see on TV
or in the movies of this world?
One like isn't sort of like as violent
as what is portrayed to be,
and you get these nut cases with guns,
putting them into people's heads.
That does not happen.
The drug abuse, that side of it,
that happens quite prevalent, I would say quite realistic.
Because again, you don't realize this
when you're in that world,
but I think people are trying to always escape
the reality of what's gonna inevitable.
What's gonna happen to you.
And you're always living in that moment.
It's like a form of escapism that you eventually,
that is gonna run its course.
That dissonance of like fronting,
like it's all gonna be good but knowing in your,
or your unconscious mind, like,
it's only a matter of time.
And it's inevitable.
Like you can't help, but everyone that you,
even, if they're not close to you,
you're always hearing about people having their doors kicked
off and the police arresting them
and someone getting arrested for this.
So it's always in your subconscious
that these things are going on,
but you kind of believe that it is never gonna happen
to you.
But I do think when I look back now retrospectively
like a lot of the stuff around the drugs and the drink
and the partying all stems back from that belief
that you know eventually that you are gonna end up
going down that same road.
And were you part of that too?
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
and again, the, I being a young man with my stepdad,
like it was never discouraged,
like never, ever, ever,
like I remember taking young friends out mine night
that we were the same age as me.
And it wasn't that many of them,
but I remember going out and him giving them drugs
and offering it to me.
Like, and I was 18.
It wasn't like, again, most fathers wouldn't do that
with their children.
But when you're in that life, that lifestyle,
a lot of people that's flag disregard.
Like they just don't care.
They don't care about anyone really,
other than that really tight grouping of people.
And whereas all the cash go,
like where you keep where do you, I mean,
is it literally under the mattress or you have places
where you're stashing it or are you laundering it,
You'd be surprised by how a lot of people live
when they do that.
They live like footballers and it's like
a never ending well of money.
So whenever they start getting to a degree
where they getting low,
they just go and commit another robbery.
And they're stealing like hundreds of thousands of pounds.
Like they're not dealing a couple of thousands or millions
sometimes, but they spend it as fast as it comes in.
'Cause it's that high octane never ending well with money.
That's gonna gonna-.
Do you, like, you gotta pay like on some,
you gotta pay some taxes though, right.
Or then you have problems that way.
So, how does that all work.
You get people setting up a lot of you start.
Just buying a lot of stuff with cash then,
that's only gonna last so long before.
You get a lot of people
that buy a lot of restaurants
and they buy a lot of industry.
Where's a lot parking there and right, right.
There's a lot of ways people get round it
like they've closed all the loopholes off the now,
but like people would, for instance,
give someone that owned a property,
whatever the value of that property was
and give it to him cash.
And that would go to a businessman
that then had half a million pound in cash.
But his house didn't really belong to him anymore.
It belonged to this criminal.
And if the criminal ever needed the money out of it,
the guard more wish a house to get the money.
And there was ways around where,
how people would sort of circumvent send the money abroad,
invest money.
People would put money into drugs.
A lot of robbery money would be invested in basically
out of elements of criminal activity.
So it is just the never ending.
But it's a lot of work, right.
So it seems like, oh easy, you pull off this robbery,
you got all this money.
But like, there's still a lot of like that focus.
Like the level of attention you have to pay
to all of those things
if it was channeled in a different direction,
if they were at Goldman Sachs,
they could probably have the same result.
Tell just the other day
I was having this conversation with a friend of mine
and I was saying about like when you look alike,
a lot of people involved in like drug trafficking.
And if you got like a kilo of drugs in south America
and you managed to get that from there,
and they're not just one kilo drugs do in tons,
across the Atlantic into Europe,
without ever sending an email,
without ever making a phone call
and you've orchestrated that.
And then the people are actively trying to show
that you are linked to it.
And you are keeping such a distance of so many people
in between you and that they can't link that back.
The intellect to do that right is incredible.
And even I used to get impressed with it sometimes.
I'm like, "How on earth?"
Like you get that from there to that level of money
from one side of the world to the other
and never even make a phone call
or never directly be linked to it.
And then you've got actively people like the DEA
and the FBI serious and organized crime
trying to link you to it.
And they can't.
And they know you're involved in it, but they can't.
(laughing) Oh my God.
All right. So.
Fast forward to you getting busted
and getting the five years.
So, yeah,
I originally I was charged with nine count of robbery.
I was at the Old Bailey.
I was 18 years old.
What's the Old Bailey?
So it's like the highest criminal court
in the United Kingdom.
So it's like the real sort of, you can't get that.
It's a Supreme court, I imagine, in America,
it's like the highest court in the land criminal court.
And I was category A, because again,
they believed I was such a high state risk as teenager
and that made it quite exceptional,
but so I couldn't be kept with young offenders.
So if you're under 21, you can't be kept with male adults.
But because I was so high security,
I had to be kept with them 'cause they believed that
'cause my uncle and my stepdad.
So I go to court, I was looking at 16 years and I was 18.
And I, to me, a kid that was like, I can't even imagine,
like I can't imagine I'm gonna be in there for that long.
And before my trial was about to commence,
I was offered a plea bargain and it was for the five years
and my solicitor said, take it, take it.
'Cause at that point I served a year and he went,
you'll do another year and a half, two and you're out.
So I took it, the police livid,
they were all sitting in the dock at the old baby.
I was in courtroom number one.
Judge Godard sentenced me, a lady,
and as I was walking down,
the police were all sitting in the Foot Well,
and I was so arrogant back then
and I looked at him and I said, it's a and a shave.
And when I'd be out of there
and I was smiling and loud laughing.
And I remember as I was walking down the steps
to take me back to the cell,
the prison officers that took me to the court
were laughing and they said,
did you see the looks on their faces?
And I said, yeah.
and I was buzzing off it.
Like, it didn't bother again that arrogance,
it didn't bother me.
And then I went to back to the prison I was held in.
And then that's when I got moved to the other prison
where I ended up going to that segregation unit
where the process of my training
and exercising really begun.
So the fitness began with the first sentence.
Yes. Yeah.
And how long were you in before you started?
Well, so you were in there for a while.
You get the solitary,
you decided to stay there for a year.
And this is where this, all this all began.
And then, then I got released.
I come out.
So you come out looking like
a totally different person.
Like no one could even really recognize me.
My mom, I look really different.
I went in there like overweight come out
I had abs and I was very skinny.
I went down to about 11 stone and I remember some people
said I looked ill and, but I felt good.
And, but you just, I relapsed.
I started going out,
very spread that you go to the gym again,
the greed, it was all about money.
I was determined then to make even more money
than before I was locked up.
And a year and a half later,
I get arrested for conspiracy to commit robbery.
And like I said, it, complete aim completely changed.
The second time,
got the two life sentences kept in high security unit
in Belmarsh.
The minute I was in there,
I knew I was gonna be in there for a long time.
I knew I wasn't gonna, there was no get outta jail cards.
There was no plea bargains. There was nothing on the table.
I was completely busted.
And no smirking in the courtroom.
No shit in a shave this time
No, no, there, there, there was absolutely nothing.
I knew like my solicitor on the first legal visit,
I said, how bad is this?
And he went, "You are 50, 50.
You're gonna get a life sentence."
And I said, "Really?"
And he said, "Yes."
He said like, it's one of the most shut and cut places
that I've seen with evidence."
And we kind of just then I just had to accept it.
And so when I went back, I knew I couldn't escape.
'Cause they made that impossible.
So again, I.
How often do people escape?
It does happen. It does happen.
It's very rare, but it does happen maybe one or two a year,
but normally it's people getting them out.
So it'd be like people going to court
and someone stopping the van on the way to court
and breaking the ground.
Not in the complex itself.
Not, not so much.
It's quite rare. That's quite rare.
Like then from high security prisons,
I don't think anyone managed to break out
in the last like 20 years.
So there's very sort of bolt down type how they've got it.
and they have, 'cause believe when I was in there,
like you would look and there is nowhere to go.
Like there is no, I can concede that point and yeah.
And I kind of just had to get my mindset back into right.
I'm here.
I can't get out. I can't break out.
My friends can't help me get out.
How do I get out of as fast as I can?
And when you hear life sentence
or two life sentences,
that doesn't mean what you think it means.
There's still this potential opportunity
that you're gonna get a parole
after a number of years.
So realistically, what did you think you were looking at?
I knew I wasn't gonna get out on my minimum tariff
straightaway, but my mindset back then Rich was
I didn't intend to serve that prison sentence.
So in my mind, when he sentenced me,
it meant nothing.
So people say to me when I got the sentence
and he said life,
you would expect it to have an impact on you.
where you'd you would that shriveled down
and you think, oh my God, my life's ended.
I didn't.
I listened to it. And it meant nothing.
I didn't respect the man that was giving it to me.
I didn't respect the police.
I didn't respect the crown prosecution service.
So to me, in my mind, when I was got that sentence was,
you can gimme what you want,
but there's no way I'm gonna sit here
and serve that whole sentence.
And like I said, like I had to think of other ways
that I could get out.
I knew I couldn't get out through running for the door,
like literal breaking out.
They made that impossible.
'cause the level of security I was on.
So it was like, whatever ways can I do to get out there.
And it was basically play the system,
do what they want me to do.
So when they took me back to the prison, I said,
what are re offended behavior courses?
Do you want me to do in?
They said, we want you to do X, Y and Z.
And I said, okay.
They transferred me out the higher security unit.
They moved me to another maximum security prison.
I turned up there and I did the courses.
And then the next year my sent this plan board,
what do you want me to do?
And it is basically like,
we want you to do this, this, this,
and you do this, this, this,
and you ticking all the boxes and they start downgrading you
through the prison system.
Is it like educational stuff or what is it exactly?
It is a mixture.
So when you sit on your sentence plan board,
you'll sit there and they say like for the next year,
we want you to get like enhanced thinking skills.
We want you to do a victim awareness course.
And we want you to do your English and maths like GSEs.
And then you do that in the following year they say,
we want you to should now do this course.
So want you to do like your A levels in English
and maths and you do that.
And then what happens as you go through year on year
on year, you basically tick all these boxes.
And then when you go on your parole hearing,
it says that you've done everything they've wanted
you to do.
It becomes impossible for the parole board to say,
we're not gonna let you out.
As long as you've not been violent in prison,
you're not been violent with staff and other inmates.
But again, I didn't even think that I would even,
I had no interest in going to a parole board.
Like my thing was,
I just needed to get outta this maximum security prison.
And it happened, it worked after two years,
they downgraded me to a category B prison.
And I think I'm out like this is my release.
Like I'm nearly out now.
So you transferred me to this open,
like this category B prison.
And I can't explain the difference in security is huge.
Like I went from being on this tiny little wing
in this maximum security prison in Yorkshire up north
to this prison where it was so open.
There was not that many prison officers walking around.
It was very sort of relaxed.
And I got there straight away.
people didn't know people.
And I said, anyone got a mobile phone.
People have mobile phones and you're not allowed
to have them obviously.
And I got a phone.
I phone up my friends that lived in the Netherlands,
my best friend Aaron, and I said to him,
I've just got transferred there and stuff.
And straight away, his first thing was, tell me
when the first opportunity you get to go will get you out.
and I know it sounds like a film,
but this is how my mindset was back then night.
When my uncle was in prison, when I was a kid,
they tried to break him out of a helicopter.
So this was always in my psychology.
Like I knew these things were possibility.
So when I'm in access to the phones, I mean,
regular contact with my friends in Holland and Spain.
And it was all about first opportunity.
Wait, and I was okay,
let me just see how things are gonna shape up.
And in 2009, my life changed forever
when I found out my friend that I was on the phone
all the time, Aaron had died to commit a robber
in an Evolent.
And that was the catalyst for me being a different person.
Was there like an initial sense of
like hopelessness or what was it exactly that shifted
before you start to channel that into a positive direction?
I remember like that stuff, people dying,
people getting murdered, people getting stabbed shot.
It never happened to me
that bad stuff happened to other people.
And I would talk to my friends and someone would say,
guess what happened to so blah, blah or so-and-so.
So I was from a young person
that I was always hearing about these things
that were going on that never happened to me.
Me and my friends were good.
You're me and you're bulletproof.
That doesn't happen.
Even I was in prison.
You're smarter.
You don't anticipate that one day
that other person's gonna be someone that you love
and care for.
So when that happened to him, I can remember
I was in disbelief and I remember sitting
in this prison cell and I was in complete disbelief.
I couldn't actually compute that he was dead.
And in the following evening on the news on channel three,
because it was so rare that these English criminals
were committing crime abroad in the Netherlands,
it made news at 10, it was our primetime news.
And I remember sitting in this prison cell
watching my prison TV,
and my friend run up to the CCTV camera
and sprayed a can of CS spray into the lens.
And the camera froze literally before he sprayed it.
and I know it was my friend.
I could tell by his eyes, I could see it was him.
And I remember sitting in that cell,
watching the last moments of his life
and in the camera crewing cut away to the car
'cause as they were getting away,
the car tire blew out the car flip.
My mate got thrown out the car
and the car was just a crumpled mess on the side
of this Dutch motorway.
And I remember sitting in that cell
and I looked at my life
and I realized that precious life is like,
that should have been me in that car.
I should have been that person.
I was the one that knee got shot by the police two times.
I was the one that had the mad car chases with the police.
I was the one that drove guns up and down.
My friend didn't.
My friend got one night,
never been in trouble with a police in his life.
He committed a crime with a group of people and one night
that cost him his life.
And then I looked at my life in that place and everything
that I was brought up to believe in about
the system, money was everything.
It wasn't. And I felt embarrassed.
It pathetic.
I looked in my life in that prison cell
and I had a 16,000 pound gold gold Rolex watch on my wrist.
In prison.
No, because again, it was how arrogant I was
because to me that was a demonstration and expression
that even though you've put me in here,
I've still got money and you can't take that off me
and you can't change me.
And subconsciously again,
it was that expression of power over the system.
It wasn't about me saying to the working man, fuck you.
Like you've got no money or anything.
It was about me demonstrating to the system
that I've got these nice things and you can't do nothing.
And again, it was controlling and I looked apathetic.
It wasn't all of these men grown up as a kid
that I looked up to and they were my heroes,
they were all old men sitting in prison or they were dead
and my friend just lost his life.
And I knew from that moment that that was me done.
I honestly, like I can't express it into words.
It was like someone switched on a light in my head
and I had this awareness of how precious your life is
as a human, and the next morning I went down
for breakfast in the communal eating area.
And there was all these guys and they were talking about
when they got out, they was gonna do this and that,
and this person was an informal
and he was a grass and he was gonna do this and that.
And I thought, I can't be around these people no more.
I can't listen to this rubbish.
And the only way I can explain it is,
if you was a drug addict and you wanted to get off drugs,
but you was locked in a crack then around drug addicts
and you're trying to get off.
And I needed, I wasn't fortunate where I couldn't get up
and walk out of that place.
I was trapped physically.
So again, all I had to then develop a way
of a form of escapism to take me out of that world.
Like take me out not just prison physically, but mentally.
And that's when training took on a far greater significance
to me in exercise.
So did you then resume that like diligent protocol
of the pushups and the sit ups and the step ups
and all of that, or was there the rowing machine there
and you just said, okay, I'm gonna try this or like.
When you were in prison,
you get limited to the amount of gym access
that you can have.
And so your gym, your wing gets gym certain times a week,
that's it?
So you get free gym sessions a week on your wing
and it's to stop you from meeting people
in different wings to pace of fights and stuff.
And when I went down the gym,
there was this guy out on the rail machine
and he was down at every session I was on
and he wasn't on my wing.
And I went up to him and I asked him, I said,
what are you doing? And he said,
I'm rain this million meters for a children's hospice.
And I said, what?
And they let you around as much gym as you want.
And he said, yes.
So I went to the prison office that works the gym.
And I said, "Can I do what he's doing?"
And he said,
if you go back up on the with sponsorship forms
and a prisoners sponsor,
you come back down and give it to us,
you can run and raise money for the children's charity.
So I went up, I went and did it come back,
gave him the shorts.
And he forms and he gave me a dispensation note.
So it was allowed me to get off the wing
to go down the gym much they wanted.
So it was to row millimeters.
And you could row it five K day, 10 K day, 20 K day.
However you went to row, it got on the Ram machine.
First session I'd done at 26 was 20 miles.
So I rode 32,000 meters.
And when I did it, I was in another world.
And I mean that like people left me alone, prisoners,
didn't talk to me, prison officers
didn't talk to me.
And I remember looking at this little monitor
in this prison gym,
and I could have been anywhere in the world.
And I just, honestly, it was like the only it's the nearest,
I could say it was like meditation.
It was a form.
It generally was like a form.
It transcended me outta prison.
I could have been anywhere in the world.
And obviously I didn't understand about endorphins.
I didn't understand about that,
but that was obviously what was happening.
I did it the next day.
I went back down 32,000 meters the next day 42,000 meters.
And then I just, it become a compulsive to go down
and keep doing the same distance.
I did the first million meters, 1,000K in a month.
And then I thought I can keep doing this.
And this is gonna help me get through my prison sentence.
So I asked if I could do another million suggest,
did that did the third million three month,
then a prisoner went to me.
If you run 5 million meters that's equivalent
from around from Britain to the America.
So it's equivalent to the Atlantic.
So I asked the prison office, I said, look,
can I just run the extra 2 million?
And it's cool thing to say that I've wrote across tonight.
But really it was because it kept me in the gym
for two more months.
As I was getting through the fourth million,
I woke up an ability in my body that I never knew
I even had.
I mean, this little bubble in a prison
you're not in the real world.
You're in this cocoon, you dunno what fitness is.
It is walked. I never been against athletes.
I didn't know what was good. What was bad?
I just knew in prison on this Ram machine,
I could whole bit of numbers than Bob next to me.
And a prison officer, Darren Davis walked behind me one day
and he looks over my shoulder and he went, wow.
He went, that is quick.
And he left.
And then a couple of days later,
he came back with all of these sheets of paper
and they had all the world and British records
on the indoor run machine.
And he gave them to me and honestly Rich
at that moment, I remember looking at this list
and I was like,
I can break some of them records now.
And I didn't think they were real.
I generally didn't.
And I've woken up this physical ability.
It in my body, I never, I never knew I had,
I was good at endurance sport and I never realized it.
And it applied the seed.
And I went back to my cell and I come back and I said,
can I do this? Can I try to break some of his records?
He went to a man called Garf Sands.
Garf Sands was the governor of this prison.
He was a deeply religious man,
like really, really religious.
And Darren went this guy prison to John.
he wants to do something his life.
He wants to change,
and I believe this could help him.
Will you let him try to break these records from prison?
And I don't wanna interrupt you,
but had you voiced your desire to transcend
your criminal upbringing and change your life?
Or were you just sort of quietly,
hitting the urg every day because had you told this guard
like, look, man, I really.
Do you know what,
I never had that conversation with him
because again, I, he.
Could just see it and you sensed it.
Yeah, he could sense a physical ability
and I think he could sense that I was a good guy.
I wasn't a horrible the way I treated people in prison,
even to the regard, like the other week.
Like, I can't even remember this,
a guy on Instagram commented on one of my photos
and I've read the message.
And I met this guy. He said he was in prison with me.
I can't remember meeting him.
And he was like, I remember the impact you had on life
when you was in prison and you was on the Ram machine,
you was encouraging me.
And he went, you made me feel so special.
And it helped me better my life.
And I can't remember, but I that's what I mean, again,
I wasn't a bully, I wasn't a horrible person.
And I think Darren could see that in me.
And he saw that I was good and he thought this guy
could do something here.
So he went around and the governor approved it.
So Darren, a lot of the prison officer,
they're not so open-minded and stuff. And.
They're trying to tick you down a peg.
A lot of them don't want this,
a lot of them then didn't want to,
I dunno if you might be, not want you to succeed,
but Darren did.
So Darren had to come in when his days off.
So he wasn't being paid by the prison.
To sit with me to basically validate the records.
And they there to set a camera up there to put a special
chip card in the Ram machine to pull, pull the data off
and take photographs and film it.
So the first record I broke was for the marathon
and I broke it by seven minutes.
And so marathon 26 per 0.2 miles.
Yes. On indoor row.
British record.
British record, right?
You broke it by seven minutes?
Seven minutes. I brought the first one by.
In your first attempt.
First attempt.
and even to the degree, I can remember.
When, when I did it, like,
I can't tell you my lack of knowledge on nutrition,
like glycogen, sugar, energy drink.
I didn't have access to it for a start.
So I didn't have gels or any of that sort of stuff.
It was only my basic knowledge.
So when I was doing the record,
I promise you a prisoner had to go and get me a SAS
of these like sugars
and I was putting raw sugar in my mouth and drinking water.
Like what you would put in your coffee.
That stuff.
So I was having to put that in his energy and obviously
like I made me start feeling sick and stuff,
but it just about got me through it.
And I remember when I broke that record,
I was laying on the gym mat after,
and I remember feeling this overwhelming
sense of achievement
and everything I'd ever wanted as a young kid to be better
than average, to achieve my life, to leave a legacy,
I felt everything I could do it it through that,
through sport.
And I could use my body as a vehicle
to get me out of that world
and not only that, but be successful.
And this was the thing that I could do to find that success.
Then from that moment,
I become obsessed with being an athlete,
like to the degree where I'd go down to the library
every Friday.
And I used to get the librarian.
She had to all the books in from the outside library
into the library.
'Cause obviously there wasn't that many prisoners
interested in sports nutrition, and trained in and stuff.
So she would've sent to get these orders
and bring them in.
And I'd have a week I'd read, read, read, read, read.
And I started understanding about physiology.
I starting to understand about sports nutrition.
Then I started reading his books, Lance Armstrong's book,
all these Olympic rowers.
What year is this?
This was in 2009.
And I started reading all these autobiographies
of all these athletes and I was like,
I've got these characteristics.
I now can be successful.
And then from that moment,
my dream in prison was being an athlete.
That was it.
Within 16 months,
I'd set eight British records and three world records
on the indoor row machine.
And I was at one point, I was the only lightweight man
in the world to have all free ultra endurance world records
at it simultaneously at one point
and that was it.
I knew that I had this ability then
and Darren said it to me when you've got the ability,
not that you are fit,
but you have the ability that you can suffer.
And if you come out prison and you waste that gift,
it'll be the biggest travesty that I've ever seen
as a prison officer.
And those words to this day stick with me in my mind,
every single time I race in that Ironman on that marathon.
I'm trying to imagine
how this must have shook up the rowing community.
I mean, to did this make news when you were doing this.
I'm picturing like the guys at Oxford and Cambridge
who are getting the print out what do you mean?
Who's this guy like he's in prison.
He broke these world records.
Like what's going on here?
Do you know what? You'll be very surprised.
He actually didn't. And the reason it didn't.
So when the records went on the system,
they wasn't being put down that I was a prisoner.
They were just put in my name and I was in Nottingham.
So there was none of that sort of fan fare around it.
The only time, like, again, it seems very cinematic.
I broke the world record for the most amount of distance
road in 24 hours on an indoor row machine.
And I rowed 265,000 meters in 24 hours.
And I remember Darren said,
start the record at four o'clock in the afternoon.
And then you'll finish at four o'clock the next day
in the afternoon because in that way,
you'll be able to go to bed that night.
And your body clock's not gonna be all outta sync.
And I remember I went back on the wing,
the following morning,
I broke that world record by 13 miles.
And when I went on it, even to, I can remember it,
they opened up the gates on this wing
and I walked on and all of the prisoners
were being kept aware of what I was doing.
They kept saying to prison officers, is he broken it?
Is he nearly gonna break it?
And what happened when I was in prison,
I become a bit of a champion because
I was competing against people outside.
And so the prisoners in prison wanted me to do it.
They wanted me to create those records.
And I remember walking on and these prisoners
were on the landings and they was all clapping
that I come on and I broke this record.
And I felt, I remember I felt shattered,
but I felt amazing. I thought, wow,
like I've just achieved something amazing.
And I've had that sort of impact all these people wanted me
to do it.
And it was an incredible feeling
and it's only since, like, since I've been out,
I've gone back to that prison
and they've got like pictures of when I broke the records
in the gym and it's absolutely incredible.
Like to know that you can plant those seeds
in other people's heads to show them
what you can do of your life.
But yeah, that was it...
It was amazing.
But then it did start becoming really frustrating
when I couldn't get out,
I broke all the records I could break.
There was none left for me to do.
I realized I had this physical potential.
I was young. I was strong.
I was the fittest or fittest rowing fit
that I've ever been in my life,
but I was trapped in prison and I couldn't get out.
I was doing these life sentences
and I remember I went for a real sort of stage
where it become so frustrating to me.
Like I knew I changed, I was demonstrating it,
I broke all these record
and people were saying how amazing it was
but they wouldn't let me out
'cause I still had year I a year left
to serve my prison sentence.
And that got delayed because
they sort of made mistake, bureaucratic mistakes.
And that led to me end up being in there three years
over what I had originally been sentenced to.
So when did you eventually get out
and how did that at work?
So my first parole hearing,
we sat there and I had to get in front,
released in front of a crown called judge.
He had to come in.
And what year is this?
This was in the first parole, 2011.
And I remember, so you get your crown called judge retired.
He sits in front of you and he's a typical parole here.
Now you can imagine that you've got your judge
in front of you directly in front of you.
You've got to his left layperson member of the public.
You've got a criminal psychologist.
You've got your probation officer sitting next to you
and your solicitor sitting next to you.
And the judgment went to me.
What are your release bands?
So I said, "I'm gonna be a professional athlete."
And he sat back in his chair and he was smiling at me
and he leap forward and he went,
"I have never heard of prisoner sit in front of me
and say that."
But I Rich, I absolutely believed it.
And I know you might think I'm making this up.
Oh, I believe, no, I don't think you're making
this up, I mean you just broke three world records.
You break them, you crush them without knowing anything
really even about the sport and having never been in a boat
and having not grown up as an athlete, I believe you.
He was like, and he's smart.
And he went, I've never heard of prisoner ever come
and say that in the all the years I've sat
life sentence or parole hearing.
So I had a criminal psychologist that does reports on you
in prison.
And he looked at him and he went,
what we are seeing today was you say,
this is all smoker mirrors
and that the criminal psychologists in British prisons,
they're notorious that people often say
a sweep of a pen can keep you in prison for years
if they believe so have to diagnose
if you've got an underlying psychological disorder.
So sociopath, psychopath, if you are,
you are a massive risk to the public.
And obviously then you're probably never gonna get until
you've gone through all these special courses
that they want you to do.
And I thought, oh my God.
You think you're delusional
Please?
And actually the psychologist said to him,
he's gone well beyond what he would've had to have
done to try to pull him away over your eyes.
He went like he could have just done a couple
level free gym instructor courses
and sat there and said the same thing
he went, but the stuff he's done, you could not black.
Like he was talking about the longest continuous row
and those things.
He went, you physically do it unless
he deeply, deeply had a desire to do it.
So the judge basically asked me to leave the room.
I went back in and they didn't release to me.
They what they done, I get it.
I don't think your release plans based in reality,
he went but I'm gonna move you to a semi-open prison
so we can slowly integrate back into society.
So they moved me to an open prison
where I was able to go out every day and work voluntarily
in a fitness first gym.
It's like halfway house.
Basically, you're still in prison,
but it all works on trust.
So if you left and didn't wanna go back, you didn't have to,
but it did integrates you back in society,
I got used to working.
I never had a job in my life.
I started working as a personal trainer in this gym,
in this little village, UP north,
and I was there for a year and a bit.
And then I ended up getting released in 2012,
after the Olympics, I get released.
I Google high performance rowing clubs in London.
And this London rowing club comes up
near partner in Southwest London.
And it was like a feeder system into the GB setup.
So I go down there and just to give people
a bit of an understanding,
physiologically for my weight for a lightweight man,
I was putting out the same,
so you get you 2K then your 5k in rowing
those numbers mean everything, that is it.
So there's minimum requirements that you have to pull
on a rail machine to even be looked at,
to become an international rower
if you don't pull those numbers,
you won't even be looked at,
they won't even watch you row in the water.
So my 2000 meter time was 14 seconds faster
what you would've needed to get into the international
GB squad.
And on my 5k, it was,
I think it was up 38 seconds faster.
So aerobically, I was much stronger over 5k,
but the problem that I had that I soon realized
was rowing is such a technical sport
that in new class as a veteran at 26, yeah.
I took it up at 29.
I was nearly 30 and I realized quite soon,
I couldn't get to that level in rowing
that I wanted to as an athlete.
So I had to make a tough decision after four months
that this isn't gonna work,
this isn't gonna facilitate me doing what I wanna do.
So I had to basically I looked around
and when I was in prison,
I saw episode of transport sport.
And there was a show called Ironman or a sport.
It was an Ironman show within it.
And I remember watching Kona
and I just remember think these men
are it's incredible.
Like watching them get off bikes
and running like two and a half hour marathons.
And it inspired me when I was in prison.
And then when I knew realized I couldn't become
a professional athlete being in a rower, I went on Google,
Googled the criteria and I thought, right,
I'm gonna go and do Ironman.
I went off on eBay and I bought a bike.
As I said, I never ridden a bike.
I was flirt now.
I taught myself to scream off YouTube videos.
Never swam.
Never ever I'm ever swam
even when I was out of prison
you might have caught me in a sea
bubbling around like when I was on holiday, but no swimming,
no nothing.
So I basically taught myself to swim.
And the only race I could do was Ironman UK.
'Cause I wasn't allowed to leave the United Kingdom.
And Ironman UK was in six weeks time
after I decided that I went to the Ironman.
So that was what I was gonna do.
I was for what I going at the deep end.
So I go into Ironman UK. I try to the race sold out.
So I had to go and get a charity ballot place
and get into Ironman UK six weeks later.
So the furthest I'd ever swam was there at the race,
the furthest I'd ever cycled was there at the race,
but I'd run, like I'd run further than that before,
like as longer than marathon.
You had run longer a marathon.
Like, so I probably,
I should have probably mentioned this earlier on.
So when I was in the open prison,
I decided to run an ultra marathon.
'Cause I was wanting to test my body.
I went to a different challenge.
So the governor there, there was the,
the gym instructors in the prison.
There was a couple of them rec like in the Royal Navy.
And then my, they retire in the Royal Navy,
they come to work in the prison service
and obviously they knew I was this really fit guy.
Come there, I broke all these records.
So my reputation sort of proceeded before I got to prison.
So all these prison officers like this guy,
that's broke all these prisons
and obviously bit of ban and stuff like that.
And one of them started talking about ultra mouth
from running and I was like, right, what is it?
And said anything over a mouth stuff.
I said, oh go.
And when I was working out in the gym,
I used to go to the library in the village
before I would go to the gym to work every morning.
So I'd had like a little half hour window
to get the bus half hour, go to this library, go in there
ultra mouth ands.
There was an ultra mouth from, from London to Brandon,
which was like 56 miles long.
And I went back to prison.
I said, look Derrick and they let me outs do it.
So like for the weekend.
So they go away.
She says, yeah, go says you could do it.
So the only running I'd ever done was on a treadmill
in the prison gym
Farthest I've ever run was 10 K on a treadmill.
And next thing you know
they've given me this snow to start the London to bright
and ultra marathon.
So they let me out,
I go down to Blackie where the London marathon starts.
And literally you run from there,
it's a trail marathon down to the coast,
and it was probably, as I said,
'cause never run one of the hardest things.
I think I'd ever done that.
I remember my legs, my quads after I finished
You finished it.
Yeah, I did it.
I did it 12 hours I did in,
and then I remember like when I was running down the hills,
I had to run backwards because my quads
were completely gone.
And then I paralyzed myself afterwards.
I got the taxi coming back and I remember the taxi driver
dropped me back from Brighton back to London
and he didn't want to take the money.
He went, I cannot believe you've run from London to Brighton
and I walked back to the prison.
All my legs were bruised up where all the swelling come out.
But yeah, it was amazing.
It was amazing.
Like 1000000% when I've finished with Ironman,
I will 100% through ultra marathon running.
Like to me it is amazing.
Like the way you feel is so hard than Ironman.
So, so, so, so much hard Ironman psychologically,
I feel like it's more challenging physically it's harder,
but I love running.
I love it.
I find like when I run now,
I don't like running with other people.
I like running on my own.
It's like a form of meditation.
I can really, I find it really hard to relax
like acts like I'm always thinking about stuff.
Like when I go running my bike,
I'm always thinking about things.
I swim, always thinking I can't switch off,
but when I run, just switch off and I could be anywhere
in the world again.
And it is near,
if not more than when I used to sit on that ram machine.
From 10K being your longest run on a treadmill,
not even running 10K like on roads or trails,
to running 56 miles on trail.
(both laughing)
It was amazing though.
And I'm still like picturing,
we've kind of put rowing in the rear view,
but you kind of rolling up on this semi elite rowing club,
having never been in a boat before and saying,
oh yeah, here's my here, you could look at these numbers.
And they're faster than probably most of the guys
in the club.
Must have been like, who is this guy?
Well, like one of the first sessions I'd done to,
I got released from prison on a Friday, Saturday morning
I go down to the club.
The head coach was who are you?
I emailed him before I come down and I said,
I'm so he was aware I was gonna turn up.
They did not take novice rowers.
But he said to me, what's your 2K time?
So I told him and he went, all right,
let's do it and he was like.
He had this philosophy and he said all the time,
you can't coach what God's given you.
And he used to say to me, if you've got a big engine,
some people just haven't and you can coach that big engine
to row well, and that's all you need to do.
That's my job.
I know you've got the row power and it's my job to teach you
how to use that power and a boat.
But if you haven't got that power,
doesn't matter how much you technically hit good.
The guy with a bigger engine will always beat you
when he learns to get that sort of the technical element.
But the problem is you just needed to get
in a boat as a much younger person.
Yes.
It's the same with swimming.
It's really hard to learn swimming when you're older,
in your later years,
it's just something that you can pick up quite easily
if you're in the right environment.
But like trying to, you can learn to run,
you can learn to ride a bike, but like swimming
it's a whole different thing.
When you see it,
when you see people like come across from doing like cycling
money backgrounds into Ironman,
like they get to a point where they just don't progress.
And the people that like those row 50,
sub 50 minute swimmers, you tend to find,
come from swimming backgrounds that have swum
their whole lives.
And they like to them pumping at those sort of times,
isn't really a challenge where like the other guys
are like trying to just get under the hour and stuff.
And they're expanding a lot more energy because,
because the people who really know how to swim,
know how to make the water work for them.
So they're so much more efficient and their output
is to mini as compared to the guy who's
just slashing water, mean.
So how did that first Ironman go?
I mean, six weeks, like there's only so much you can do
in six weeks,
especially when you don't know how to swim.
So like the guys,
there was a couple guys at the rowing club that like,
were there just recreation and we were chatting about it.
And like, one of them said to me, he said,
"Look, there's no point you going out doing
a massive like rides now because you've never in a bike,
you probably get injured.
So you imagine just ride the distance in the race.
When I race, I see this as an athlete.
So I've nearly been killed two times.
Literally been to time where I'm fractions
of inches away from a policeman shooting me dead.
In the big picture of things in life,
like I've nearly lost my life.
So I look at everything like that through that lens.
So there's a really doing a wreck
doing a swim in Ironman.
It's not really that big of a deal or getting on a bike,
riding a bike, like it's just physical activity.
Exact exercises is no real great significance
other than that, like, I'm not gonna lose my life doing it.
And I just put every inter realistic terms of like,
when I've had my life taken off me for 10 years,
that's a lot of stress to go through.
Like when you're an Ironman, I see that as some privilege,
I'm there that morning,
I'm physically able to do it one day.
I won't be able to like,
and I see it as a massive honor and privilege to be there
and be able to physically do it and compete it.
And I did that morning, I turned up,
I didn't have any fear whatsoever.
And I thought, just experience it, see what it's like.
And do you know what,
the only thing that I really got from it,
but man it was amazing when I finished it
like to watch that TV show in prison and then be there
and actually do it and run down that red carpet
was incredible.
But it was when I was on the bike,
one of the pro guys went past me.
And even though I'd never obviously rid that he lap me
'cause it was like free loops, the same circuit.
And I thought that will never happen to me again
in an Ironman race.
I remember that and that those were the things
that really stuck with me and I finished the race
and I thought, right,
I didn't honestly rich. I didn't feel that touched by it.
I didn't feel, I felt comfortable.
I felt I was within myself.
Like I didn't feel like I was gonna blow up.
I wasn't massively quick, like Ironman UK's quite hilly.
And I did it at like 11 1/2 hours.
So I finished, I think 100 fat
about three and a half thousand people
actually felt.
11 1/2 in six weeks without knowing
how to swim and having never rid a bike.
I was very row fit.
Yeah, I get that.
But yeah, and then I thought what
this is what I'm gonna do.
This is it.
And then I started, I made a lot of errors then
because then I thought it was too easy.
And I thought I would train how I trained on a Ram machine
in prison, the same Ironman.
So I went from basically never really being a runner
to running nearly a marathon every Saturday, Sunday morning,
around Battey park within eight weeks,
I could comfortably run sub three hour marathons.
It wasn't hard it like I remember and what happened
It become very addictive because I was talking to guys
and they were like,
they were talking about like running a sub three at London.
I was thinking that's not hard.
Like I can do that in training. I do it all the time.
I'll do it every Saturday.
And I got quicker and quicker and quicker.
and the same from bike.
I was riding indoor bikes.
What bikes in the rowing club,
my watch just got bigger and bigger and bigger.
'Cause I kept training as hard as I could every session
'cause they're suffering.
And you're freewheeling it though.
Like you're not working with the coach.
No program. No, nothing.
And again, that was something,
this is something that stuck with me
from being a kid distrust.
Like I thought to myself there, and this is my goal,
this is my dream, not someone else's
and I don't trust anyone else with this
and I thought I knew better.
I thought that I could do this myself.
And as I said, I dug myself into the biggest hole.
Like I was sweating.
I was waking up in the early hours and when sweating,
I was getting up early and then to me,
then it become how much do I like,
even though I feel like crap,
I'm just gonna go out and just keep hammering it.
And I gonna hammer it.
And again, I just kept digging this hole
and I was getting quicker,
but my body wasn't recovering, it was breaking down.
It was breaking down.
And then I ended up really getting sick.
I went on a training camp and I remember went
for a swim one morning and I couldn't breathe.
And I thought, what?
Like, I've never felt anything.
I could not breathe, physically breathe.
And I got outta water.
And then later on that I was in the car.
Couldn't breathe again.
And obviously I was having like a panic attack
where I was draining the life out my body got a virus,
then went back to Ironman, Katie,
the following year and just absolutely fell apart.
It was the most humiliated I'd ever felt in my life.
I felt worse that day than I ever did
being in any of those courts,
getting that life sentence that I felt ashamed.
Well, my friends, Terry come up,
my really close friend and Darren,
the prison officer come up.
And I remember like them being on the side of the course.
I feel I let everyone down.
They put a lot of time and I come away from that race
and I realized I didn't have the skills to coach myself.
Or the humility.
The humility is the big lesson there
going from this stubborn guy who thinks he knows best.
You can't be a great athlete without
the humility to be able to take direction
from people who want to help you.
Totally, and I had to realize that,
but I had to realize it in that moment
that had to happen to me.
That had to happen.
Otherwise you were unteachable.
Totally.
So your most impressive world record
is perhaps a world record from going from complete novice
to over trained in the shortest period of time.
(both laughing)
I went from like lit literally zero hours
for Ironman training to like 35, 40 hours a week
just as hard as I could do it.
That was always that.
The body can't absorb that much that quickly.
But I thought he could.
And I, and again, I thought he could,
'cause I was thinking I rode two hours a day,
every day in prison on the rail machine.
I remember like some of those sessions
when I was in prison on those rail machines
and I got to like a couple million meters
and it was every day,
like there was no rest days and my hand 10 days,
like the tenders of my hand coming like a claw
and you could unclick my fingers.
So I knew I had that propensity to push myself that hard.
And to me, that suffering of getting up in the morning,
feeling like crap because I was over training
was to me an expression of how much I wanted this goal.
'Cause it was like, I can suffer more than other people
and that really become my Achilles tendon.
But it was the best thing that happened to me
falling apart that day.
Better then than now.
So it must have taken you a while to climb out of that hole.
I had to go to the hospital and I had ECGs down
to make sure I didn't mess my heart up.
I just had a re I had post viral fatigue.
I was very fortunate that my body did kind of,
I ran a couple of months.
I didn't stop training completely,
but I completely backed off.
Like I still,
the longest I've not exercised for him since 26 years old
or 25 was probably last year.
And I had 12 days off completely.
I'd done literally no exercise.
And that was, it's such an ingrained part of me.
Like I couldn't ever imagine,
not being physically active at of just doing something.
Even that means me getting up and going for like a 10 K run
or something like that.
Like that was, but I've learned,
that's what I've learned about my body.
I've learned, I need to do that.
I can't, especially as I get a bit older,
I can't keep sort of like going to the well all the time
and putting the bucket down
and I'm trying to just absorb loads and loads
and loads of load.
I have to be a bit more intelligent with stuff.
I mean, that's quite the arc.
Like if you go to your website,
like right there on the homepage,
it's like you have all the people that comprise your team
that are helping you.
So from that guy, who's so stubborn,
who thinks he knows everything
and won't let anybody tell him anything
to having what I saw when I looked at your website,
I was like, oh, that's humility.
Like he understands that this is a team effort
and that you can't do what you do alone.
We have Terry here who, I mean,
is this around the time where Terry,
comes into your life?
No, Terry coming into my life,
well, Terry coming into my life when I was working
in the gym.
So when I was working part-time.
Terry was a member and a gym instructor.
It was help like work with Terry,
sometimes doing massage with him,
come up to me one day said,
see that guy up there he's like a sports psychologist.
And all I had was sport.
So even I introduced this to Terry,
Terry was on like a treadmill and I'd gone up
and I've just introduced myself.
And I think Terry thought, who is this guy?
And then obviously we sat down and I told Terry
my backstory.
Guy with the crazy eyes.
Yeah, yeah.
Who is this man and stuff?
And we just struck up this friendship.
And Terry was like, he paid an interest to me
and that he wanted to help me.
And again, there was no agenda.
And then when I used to get out on a Sunday,
I was so far from London 'cause I was up in a near,
just outside Darby, which is about 200 miles away.
So I couldn't commute to London and go back up
and my usually get like something a town visit,
you'd be out of prison for 12 hours.
And me and Terry used to go out for dinner or lunch
in the local town.
He would take me out for a Sunday dinner
and we'd sit there and we'd talk about stuff.
And then he was really just part of my journey ever since.
And Terry was one of the first people I'd say
that I really, really did trust.
Like I really opened up and everything I've gone into
do in my life.
Like without him being part of it,
it wouldn't be where it is today.
He's been a massive part role of what I do.
And again, it doesn't matter how driven and focus you are,
you need good people around you to help you reach
your potential in life.
And it works both ways.
I'm just sure Terry's learned things from
the experiences that we've been through and vice versa.
And it's been amazing to share it with someone else as well.
Right, right, right, right.
And then you bring on somebody whose triathlon specific.
And then he's been, yeah.
The physical element of it.
So we did some training sessions before that Ironman,
I fell apart and he knew how fit I was,
'cause he saw through some of the training stuff
that we were doing together.
And then when we did Ironman UK, he finished fourth,
fifth overall.
and I finished like a hundredth and he went like,
like he ran past me when I was walking on the marathon
You had your way.
Now we know what happens when you do it your way.
And he time to do it my.
Way he reached out to me and he said,
"Look, I'll coach you for free.
I just wanna help you just be the best athlete you can be.
And I've been working with him for the last
sort of three and a bit years."
So then when was your big breakthrough race?
Probably Frankfurt.
Yeah, that was quite a step up.
You went nine or sub.
Nine, nine.
You went nine even.
I'm always learning.
The bike has really been the thing I've been learning
the most, like the running, for instance,
like my Ironman marathon's like three hours.
I can get off and run a three hour marathon,
fairly comfortable.
Like it's not really a push,
but the bike's been the thing where it's not been the power
it's been just the lack of riding is,
and that the like taking corners too wide,
breaking too much.
And that starts adding up a lot over 180K.
And then sometimes I've looked at races where guys
that make my weight are putting out similar numbers
that I'm putting out and they're like 15 minutes up the road
for me.
And you can't give that sort of time away to be.
You have to learn how to translate that engine
that you have into speed.
And it is coming.
Hopefully it comes in three weeks time.(chuckles)
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, do you live in London proper?
Yeah.
You do.
So where do you go to train and do your long rides?
So I go out to Windsor.
So after you leave, when you leave mine,
you've got like a 20 minute,
a bit with traffic and stuff.
And then it's kind of just flat fast roads
going out to Windsor castle,
or you've got the Sury Hills again,
it's another 15, 20 minutes getting out.
And then you get clearer roads around like all around
the Sury Hills and stuff,
which is quite nice running Richmond park down the Toby off.
Like that's one of my favorite runs all the way down
to Tobar like you could run from,
you can run from basically Patney, Southwest London,
all the way up to Tums.
This is actually an ultra math and the Tums 100,
it's just at the side of the slope off.
Right. Cool.
And the swimming you do,
there's a pool where you get out and open water or.
You high park.
So you got to surf up in time.
Or mostly other time I just swim in Lidos.
So there's quite a few of them dotted around London.
And do you train alone?
Yes.
What's the community like here.
It's quite good. Southwest London.
You tend to find a lot of guys at Kona.
The Brownie live in town here?
No, they live up in Leeds.
So they're northerners, but like a lot of-
Tim Dons in Boulder.
Yeah, Tim.
But a lot of the, I think he's been Trickin originally
he where he grew up.
He grew up in Trickins.
That's that's not too far away from Richmond.
It's about 15 minutes away.
But a lot of really good Ironman triathletes
actually live around Southwest London.
So a lot of guys that are very, very good age groupers,
like are based that way.
So you do get some decent guys going out,
but I do train on my own a lot.
You strike me as the you're a lone Wolf.
I do go out riding sometimes with people
and then I think, why have I done this?
It's different if you go, like I go out.
Sometimes it it's hard sometimes.
'Cause I got guys at row and now are very, very fit,
but then they wanna push the pace too much.
And it's too, too, too hard.
The discipline is you gotta do what,
you gotta fulfill the intention for that working out.
And when you're training for Ironman or ultra endurance,
a lot of that discipline plays into holding back.
'Cause everyone it's,
there's a Dick measure in contact.
Yeah, totally. (laughs)
I didn't wanna put it like that.
But yeah,
When she said it's like Willie waving,
everyone was just like,
see how quick they can go up a climb
and then they all blow up.
And then you are all sort of they're limping back coming.
Like they have a week.
I went riding with a friend of mine at a Henley.
It's like 100 mile ride.
And I said, are you sure you wanna come?
He went, yeah, I'll sit on your will.
So I said, okay,
So we're averaging like 35K an hour
and he's on the back wheel and we got to start
open stretcher road and he's come out behind me
about 60 can ride tore off.
And I thought, what I do,
I'll just keep him that 10 minute gap.
Just do a bit of practicing.
So I'm not drafting him
a bit of Ironman work and he's looking behind
and he thinks he's dropped me and I'm thinking, oh, go on.
I he's looking around, and I can tell,
he thinks I've dropped him half a while.
I'm just gonna have to let him see now.
So I've come up and his wheel closed the gap
and then just tour around him and gone.
And he's like, wow, like he can't
You weren't supposed to that.
Wasn't part of what you were supposed to.
Be doing that. But what.
You can't help it.
What happened to him? When we were coming back,
he was quite tan.
And I looked at him and he started going like,
do you see someone going Ash white?
And I says, you're right.
He's like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And he went, no, I'm not even, I really feel back.
And we stuff get a Marsal.
And we used to be able to put over to side the shop
and he got and that so that's probably a lot,
a lot of the reasons why I don't like training other people.
Well, here you are today
and you have fulfilled this promise,
this aspiration that you articulated to the parole board
of being a professional athlete.
I mean, you are a professional athlete.
You're a Nike sponsored athlete.
You're the only triathlete that Nike sponsor.
Ironman.
Ironman triathlete.
Wow, man, how did that come together?
How can I put this, Rich?
It was like fairy tale.
Honestly it was one of the biggest things in my life.
Like as an achiever,
a man that was in prison at like 26 that said,
I wanna be a professional athlete.
People laughed that people said you'll never had to do it.
Took up school till late. You'll never do it outta prison.
You're a prisoner. you re offend.
It was hard when you get out,
like you're never had to do that.
Like you are just slipping 12 crowds and you're start
getting involved in robberies and that is me
but at prison over trained, got sick,
made decisions to get a coach, carried on it,
believe in every day.
I honestly, there's one thing I visualized
and believed every day, everything I was doing
would pay off.
I knew it.
I knew it. I didn't know what it would be.
And I just- [John]
Where does that knowingness come from?
Self-belief, I always believe whatever I put in
my mind at.
I believed when I was a kid that I'd be a multimillionaire.
I've just always had it in me,
this intrinsic thing.
That's this overwhelming need to want to do something great
with my life, from being a young kid.
And that's that belief that I could do it.
I've never lacked that belief.
Like my mom said this to me recently she said,
even when I was little,
she would take me to that summer camp
and all of these kids would be in a corner
and they'd all be looking around, never knew what to do.
And I'd just off on my arm and do it.
So like it was rock climbing.
Everyone's there just be, wait for thing.
I'd put the thing on and I'll climb the wall.
And then sometimes I didn't put the safety
so they got mad at me.
But I've always had that in me.
Like I would always be very assertive and I'd like, bang,
I'm gonna do it and do it from being a young boy.
And I had that belief and I remember I was at prison
for two years, I over trained.
And I was around my mom's one day.
And I remember like I was talking to my mom
about it and I said like, "I cannot,
and will not give up on this."
And I had the CCG box on my heart from the hospital.
They went to money for 24 hours and I went,
I know mum will payoff.
And my mom said,
"Just carry on doing what you are doing
and follow your dream, do not stop."
And I didn't.
And I went up and I raced again the following year
and I had a much better result.
And then the Christmas before last,
Terry, that was obviously been massive part of my life,
he acts as a bit of a fire or he runs my website
and every day we ring each other out in the morning
and he says, these are the emails
that have come through last night or yesterday.
And we talk about maybe a school wants me to go in
and do a talk, a prison,
whatever it is, it be something.
And he said, now I'm back to saying,
it's gonna change the rest of your life.
So I said, "What?"
And he went to me, "Guess who sent us an email last night?"
And I went, "Who?" "I mean guess?"
And I went who?
And he went, "It's a massive brand."
And again, it wouldn't even compute.
And I said, "Who?" He said, "Nike."
And I was like, no.
And then believe you, he went, I'm gonna send you an email.
And he that one,
and it was a guy called Dan Smith that worked in London,
head of track and field.
And he basically said that they become aware of my story
and they felt inspired.
And at the time I had like a relationship
where I was an ambassador for a clothing range.
It was another sportswear company called Craft.
And they were giving me like t-shirts and stuff
to raise him.
And Dan said, in the thing, like,
have you got any contractual obligations?
And Terry said to me on the phone, he went, look,
do you wanna talk to him or shall I?
And I said, "I trust you implicitly. You talk to him."
Terry rang him up and had a conversation with him.
And it was two and fro, two and fro two and fro.
Then it went really cold and I was like 10 Terry, like,
this means everything.
Like to me, what I'm trying to do in my life,
like this could aid so much to it, Rich,
not just as an athlete,
but what it allows me to do and what it represents.
and it went cold heat back up.
and they said to Terry,
can John come into the London office
and do a talk to the staff?
So me and Terry go down to Soho and do his talk for an hour.
And at the end there was 100 of them in there.
It was like a little cinema.
And they was all sitting down on the aisles
and in the chairs.
And literally there was a line of them coming out
and every single one of 'em shook my hand when they're out.
And they said like, it's incredible.
And then Dan was standing next to me and he went,
"I've seen them being spoken to by some massive athlete,
and I have never, ever, ever seen them react to someone
like that."
And I said to Terry, when we left that talk, I said,
"Do you think like that's got me a of line with him."
And Terry says, "You are in."
And in two weeks later, Dan emails back and says,
can Jon come out to the Netherlands
and talk at our European conference?
It'd be about 850 people from like global.
So people from the states would come to it.
Terry says to me, can you go?
I had to ask my probation officer and I said,
"Look, they Nike want be Scott there."
So they said, she said, look,
you can go say cleared it.
I got to Netherlands.
We go to this auditorium the day before,
where we're gonna do a practice run
of what we're gonna do that day.
And then I meet this guy called Edgar,
and I didn't realize how powerful it was within the brand.
So he said VP market in Europe.
So he's one of the most powerful influential man in Nike,
within Europe.
So I meet him and we go finish stress rehearsal.
So we are gonna open up this massive conference,
these 850 people and it was called the powerful with him.
So it was about normal people achieving extraordinary
things, no one in this auditorium,
know anything about me 'cause no one knew me in the brand.
Like we all new to them.
So we do our dress rehearsal.
And then we go out for dinner that night.
So we're sitting in this restaurant in Amsterdam
and Edger sitting next to me and he was saying to me about,
"Do you know how we sponsored you?"
So I said, "Dan", he said, "No."
He said, I was reading about you at airport in Holland
in Skipal,
and I read this sports supplement
and I got halfway through and I put the paper down,
I got my phone out and I sent an email to London.
I said, find that man and sponsor him.
And he was talking to me and he was telling me a story
about years before that, when he was a young guy
working at Nike,
when he first he's been in the brand now for 32 years.
And he said there was an ice skater in Holland
in the Netherlands.
And he said, the man was beautiful, charismatic, charming,
good looking, outspoken.
And I went to the round and I said about sponsoring him.
And at the time Nike didn't sponsor ice skaters.
And he went, I always regretted that we never got him.
And the next year become Olympic champion European champion.
And he went, become this massive superstar in Holland.
And I always thought, like only I have got him and went,
I always promised myself, well,
I ever got to a position in the brand
where I could make that decision, I'd make it.
And he went and when I saw you,
my heart told me it was the right thing to do.
And that's how it all sort of come about
and When they reached out to me initially,
obviously as an athlete, it's the pinnacle
like Lance Armstrong was a massive hero of mine in prison
when I read his books, Nike,
Michael Jordan, Mo Farah, Paul Radcliffe,
all of these endurance athletes that I aspire to be like,
we're all under that brand
and to me as an athlete, it meant everything.
It meant like me realizing a dream.
What I really come to realize the power that
that has that night swoosh,
when you go into schools is unbelievable to young people.
And I make conscious effort when I go to schools
and I talk to young people, I do not scare them into crime,
not committing it 'cause it does not work fact.
It's been proven time and time again, you can't scare them.
But every kid wants to be a Nike athlete.
Yes.
Or there's a rapper or musician
or an actor that is wearing that.
They see that as success.
They don't care about Ironman.
They don't care about the records. They see the swoosh.
And when you're part of that,
you're part of like the England football team,
all of these things that these kids are seeing
as being successful and I can demonstrate to them
and I don't preach, I just explain, I say,
this is a set of decisions I chose to make as a young man.
This is what happened.
Then at that point, when I decided to do that,
this is what's happened.
You don't need to do that to achieve your dreams in life.
You can do positive things with life
and you can achieve your dreams.
That doesn't mean every kid's gonna be an athlete.
But that night rush to me was my dream.
And I said, if I've managed to achieve that my life
from being that kid that was ripped off
and spent all those years in prison
and I've made my dream come real,
you can make your dreams become reality
and the proofs and the pudding.
And when you can demonstrate it and show that
to those young people, it is such a powerful thing.
Like I've gone into assemblies where there's been like
six, 700 kids and you can hear the gasps
when you turn around at the end and say,
and you go click the slide last slide the night.
And they're like,
and they all click stand out with stand innovation.
And it's so powerful to really connect
into some of most disenfranchised young people
in the country.
And it's symbolically just underscores
the incredible arc of your journey
because you are in a situation where few people get
that low and there's few things,
more heralded or more coveted
than being a Nike sponsored athlete.
Like it's just, that point to the,
from A to Z is insane.
And beyond that, like let's not forget
the compressed time period that we're talking about here.
This wasn't 20 years ago.
When did you get outta prison? 2012?
2012 at the end.
It's like, that was yesterday, man.
Do you know what, when I was writing a book,
I was fortunate, I got off an opportunity
to write out book and it was really, really tough.
When I got the opportunity, it was hard to take it
because I knew I was gonna leave myself wired open
to be critiqued and people to criticize.
But I knew that book would be a key to a door
that would give me a platform to do good
with the rest of my life.
And it was the reason why I sort of chose to do it.
And the ghost writer that did it with me,
we did these sit-ins.
We used to do two sit-ins every month and it would,
the book was written quite quick.
It was written within four months, five months,
but we do these sittings and I'd be telling him,
and sometimes, I've to be quite honest with you,
I wouldn't be sort of as open with some of the stories
to elaborate 'cause it embellished stuff.
Like I didn't really wanna put too much detail
'cause I thought I'd be involved in other people
that I didn't really,
I went to keep the book all about sort of me
and not talk about other people.
'Cause I knew it could open up Pandora's box of
cause me issues later on in my life and stuff.
And so I was very control with how the book was written
and I was very sort of mindful about what I said.
And I remember like you sit there sometimes and like
you could see, he was like thinking really like,
and what happened, he never met no one else in the story.
And then he met Terry and then him and Terry met each other
one of my races and he was having a conversation with Terry
and he was like, is this for real?
And Terry was like,
So, he wasn't buying it.
No.
He thought
you're full of shit.
I think in some ways he thought
it was all pre-planned
like I was like sociopath.
I was thinking about this later on in my life,
like when I was in prison, I was like, oh,
I'm gonna do this and do that, do this.
And then he couldn't get,
I think the thing that he really struggled with was
a lot of people helped me for nothing.
He couldn't get that.
Everything sort of about money.
It was like, but they must have seen,
they must have seen something in it.
Like they must have been something in it.
They must have seen there was an opportunity in them
to help themselves later on.
I was none, there was none of that.
Darren didn't do what he'd done all his years ago
thinking that I'd be where I am today.
Terry didn't think six years ago where I'd be
where I am today.
Like, well what's happened there wasn't
and sometimes we would sit there, as I said, dude,
he sittings with him and he generally didn't believe it.
And then once he got involved,
then what's happened afterwards
he rings me up now.
And like he's, my life has never been normal.
Like from being a young kid.
it hasn't even, I can admit that that's some like Rich,
like not many people know this.
So last year I got invited to houses parliament
to meet the minister, to talk about using sport in prisons
and in the community to stop kids from making bad decisions.
The meeting ends, she says to me,
would you like to come on the veranda parliament
to come to this boxing event?
So I said, yeah.
So we walked through,
I go to this boxing event and it was a bit of a showcase.
It was about more boxing clubs in London
to get more kids engaged in sport.
There was at all these young GB Olympic boxers,
they was all doing a Q&A,
there was a young Muslim got guy there from Bolton.
And he wasn't very articulate guy said to him,
why did you take up boxing?
And he went, 'cause I didn't wanna be a bum
sitting on the streets, taking drugs.
And he went, when I was a kid,
I watched Amir calm fight at the Olympics when he was 16.
And I looked and he was like, at that time he was eight,
nine years old and he went, when I'm that age,
I wanna go to Olympics and fight for my country
and win a gold medal.
And anyway, he went to Rio.
He come full and he was gutted.
And he went back when I go back to take win a gold medal
for Britain.
And I thought this kid is incredible. Like is amazing.
Is everything, what sport is to me?
And then I left and as I was walking out for the car park
parliament to get a tax it all screaming look up.
And like from here 10 feet away,
I walked straight into the middle the terrorist attack
at Westminster and I watched the guy get shot dead.
And I saw the policeman running towards me
and collapsed on the floor.
And he obviously, I didn't realize at the time
the guy had stabbed him to death, but I didn't see
that part of it.
I just saw the guy getting shot.
And I remember I got locked in part that night,
the whole thing was on a lockdown.
It was complete light.
You can imagine older politicians,
we all got put in this like room.
And then we all got locked there to like 10 o'clock
that evening.
And then when I left-
And you're actually kind of mentally
and emotionally equipped to handle this
in a way that everybody else isn't.
Even when it happens,
because you're in an environment where you don't expect
to see what you are about to see
and that was the thing that took me out.
But what happened when I left that night,
that I remember they let us out one at a time
and they took all our names and addresses and details.
And they said, have you witnessed anything?
And I said, I saw the guy shoot him.
And then they all stopped.
And they was like, cause they didn't expect someone.
You don't talk to police was taking notes from everyone.
And then my guy says, you actually saw it.
And he's like, what?
So then he took my name address and he said, okay,
you were gonna clash you as a priority witness
'cause you've actually witnessed the event.
And I remember walking out the house is a parliament
and it was about half 10, 11 o'clock at night.
And the street were dead.
Like there was no one walking around,
there was cords and you could see blue lights flashing
but they was no sirens.
It was dead.
And I remember walking out there and I thought
there is no way on earth.
I saw that for no reason.
There was no way, like the chances of me being there,
that moment being with all those Islamic suicide bombers
all those years before listening to that young Muslim kid,
talk about what sport meant to him
and then coming out and then witnessing that
the chances of me being there were so small
that I thought that I don't believe in God,
but I generally believe there's something where
I was meant to be there and see what I saw,
'cause it made me unbelievably driven
to continue doing what I'm doing.
I can remember that I walked home
and I woke up the next morning and there was a guy
that was with me, he was in the army that day
and he tried to save the policeman's life
and he was a battle train medic, like been to sander,
been out to Afghanistan.
Batard like he was a hard man in that regard.
And I said to him,
there was a reason why me and you were there
and saw what we saw to continue doing what we are doing.
And he delivers lots of courses into prisons
because what I saw that day
was a man that was disenfranchised with society,
that hated the system.
I chose to attack it through taking money from it.
He chose to attack it through committing terrorism.
But somewhere along the line, he got lost somewhere.
And someone come into his life and walked his, where,
what he thought was right and wrong.
And in my head, I thought that is totally preventable.
You can stop that stuff from happening
by stopping those people from having that mindset
where someone negative can come in and not brainwash them,
but completely warp what is right and wrong.
It begins with the disenfranchisement.
Exactly.
And if you're too late to address that
it's too late and that stuff happen
but that's a profound awareness.
I mean that synchronicity of events is pretty remarkable.
It's almost surprising to hear you say that
you don't believe in God given what you've experienced
and how far you've come.
And when events like that,
that seemingly don't make sense on paper occur,
it's hard for me to hear that
and not that there is a purpose and a plan
and some kind of map laid out for you.
Do you know what, what was quite powerful?
I did a book festival last year,
like November and it was in a very affluent area the country
of the most expensive places to live.
And they invite me to go down and do sort of a talk
about the book and a Q&A.
And I've gone in the room and I said,
what's site the demographic for the area and they went,
you probably won't get anyone under the age of 60,
very wealthy, retired, very white, middle to upper class.
They start letting the guests in,
I'm sitting there and I'm looking around
all these old people and I'm like,
they're really gonna start trying to grill me on the Q&A
at the end.
And what happened was when we finished,
they come up and they were offering me money.
They were saying like, we want to give you money,
like for what you are doing.
And I was saying, look, I can't take your money,
but when my foundation's up.
You gotta have a foundation.
That's went live a couple weeks ago.
Oh wow.
And I said, look, I can't take money with funeral,
but when it's set up, please donate to it.
And the money will go to sort of working with young people
and then a priest come up to me and he went,
can I ask you something?
And I said, what?
He said, Has your book got a religious connotation to it?
Redemption? And I said, no.
And he said, are you religious?
And I said, no.
I said, I used to be, but I kind of,
I fell out of love with, I grew up as a Catholic,
but I lost that when I went to prison to honest.
And the reason why, before I ever used to commit a crime,
I always used to pray.
I'd get away of it.
And I know that sounds war, but I did.
I did like, my stepdad was really Catholic,
my Nan and granddad devoutly
and I got arrested and I went to prison
and that completely and utterly switched me off.
I didn't believe in it from that moment onwards.
And he put his hand on my shoulder and he went to me.
I have never seen a man put on earth
to do what you are doing right now.
He went is so clear to me went,
and you might not believe in God
but I believe God's got a bigger plan for you.
And again, I don't believe,
but it was quite a powerful moment where I was like,
and he was looking at me and I was like, wow.
Like, I didn't know, really not what to say because
it was something so above me where he could quite,
he could see something,
what I'm trying to do in my life today
that I've been put here for a purpose.
Like I said, like, I believe, I don't believe in God,
but I do believe things happened for a reason.
And I think I was there, what I saw that day
and I think my stepdad coming into my life when I was a kid,
the people that I met in prison,
my stepdad taught me of good things.
I can't just blame him for sort of warp my perspective
of life.
He taught me a lot of skills when I was a kid
that have aided me as an adult.
One was never just hanging around with criminals.
When I was a young boy,
he went always make sure you mix with different groups
of people and that's allowed me then to be able
to converse with different groups of people at the time
and not be like, I can only talk to like criminals
or I can only talk to school kids.
Well, I would echo that priest sentiment.
I can certainly understand why your relationship
with Catholicism fell out of grace,
but I think there's a difference between religious dogma
and having a spiritual connection to something greater
than your self.
And I would certainly echo his thoughts in saying that
that you're on the path that you're meant to be on.
It's super inspiring that,
and it's quite a remarkable tale
and we gotta land this plane,
but I gotta know what's going on
with the crime syndicate now.
And how's your mom?
The crime syndicates fell away, basically.
All of them are in prison
Fell apart.
All of them are in prison.
My stepdad's never been out since I went in,
when I was a teenager.
Do you go and visit,
do you stay in contact or you've completely.
I cut them all out.
I cut all my dad's side of the family out.
So you've see my mom, but my mom's side were all legitimate.
My co-defendant he got released from prison recently,
I found out.
But yeah, everyone else is they're even in prison
or dead.
And my mom, my mom's good.
I see my mum all the time.
I'm still really close to her and she gets all
the trophies and medals and everything.
I put they're all round her house in vases
My mom's mega supportive
and I think it's so nice now
to make my mom proud of what I'm doing.
But my mom was always proud of me,
even when I was in that high security prison unit.
I remember she come up
and she's left running the visits one day.
And she said to me,
it was one the only time she saw me in prison,
but the first time she was like, "I'm so proud of you."
And I was like, yeah, mom.
But she is. She's amazing.
She's your mum. Mum's love you unconditionally.
And she always has, and it's so nice now,
when the neighbors say I saw Jonathan on TV
or like the radio sees me in the magazine,
like she buzzes off it.
Yeah, of course.
Wow. It's such an incredible story.
And I feel like it's just beginning for you.
That's the beautiful thing is like this whole thing
is just starting, you know?
And I see a rich future ahead for you
and the opportunity to impact a lot of lives.
Thank you.
So what is the, to kind of end this,
what is the one sort of sentiment that you wanna make sure
you impact to somebody who might be listening to this
who is struggling or can't find their way forward.
I'm not talking about necessarily somebody
who's incarcerated, but somebody who just feels stuck
in their life and is frustrated
and feels like opportunity has alluded them.
I think it's quite simple and I know,
it's just never give up
and always believe it can get better, 'cause it can.
And I think life is so precious and you are alive
and you're breathing and then one day we won't.
So you're winning the battle 'cause you're still breathing.
And I believe that every day,
like there's days I get up and you have a bit of an off day
and you just, but you have to be appreciative.
I was out my bike the other day and I was riding along
and I thought, wow, I'm alive.
And I love this life life.
So lovely, it's precious, we are here.
The chances of us being here right now,
trillions and trillions of one,
you probably got more chance winning a lottery
million times over less actually breathing air.
So just be appreciative of it
and just believe that it can always get better,
no matter how dark that hole is,
you can always get out of it and I've done it.
And if I've done it,
I don't think I'm any different to anyone else slightly.
If I've managed, do it, anyone can do anything in life.
I think that's a good way to end it.
Thanks for talking to me, man.
Thanks, Rich.
Really incredible.
Much luck in the upcoming Ironman.
What are the other races you're doing this summer?
I'm challenge our mirror in the Netherlands.
Is the goal qualify for Kona
or what is the kind of longer term.
Just to finish as high up in the field
as I possibly can and be in a mix of everyone.
And trying to break that sub for hour marathon
and an Ironman's cool that's gonna be.
Well, come back and talk to me next time.
I'm in London.
Thanks, Rich.
Let me know if you're parole officer
lets you come to LA.
(both laughing)
If you're digging on John,
the best way to connect with him at John McAvoy,
pretty much everywhere, at johnmcavoy.com.
That's it. Right.
And are you ever doing like talks to the public
where people can come and see you?
Like, do you have a schedule on your website
with public appearances?
Not, not at the moment.
No, I do mostly school stuff, but yeah,
I probably in the future I'll probably start doing a bit
more public speaking in the context of like events,
but normally it's either schools, prisons,
or maybe sort of business or talks.
And remind me the name of the book.
Redemption.
I'm gonna read your book.
All my offices role is in profits
go into school projects.
And is there a different website
for the foundation?
Not currently. No.
So you go to my website and all the gonna be on there.
Cool, all right, man.
Thank you.
Much love.
Take care.
Right? Peace.